I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies.
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极的办公室重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有两个亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。
Hello. Hi there. Office Ladies. Hello. Hi there. Happy 200th episode of Office Ladies. Wow. 200th. I can't believe it. And you know what?
你好。嗨。办公室女郎。你好。嗨。祝贺《办公室女郎》播客迎来第200集。哇。第200集。真不敢相信。你知道吗？
What? It's Dwight's Christmas. I know. What a special episode for our 200th episode. But before we break that down, we have a very special guest with us today. It is our very own Sam Kiefer. Hi, everybody.
什么？是德怀特的圣诞节。我知道。对于我们的第200集来说，这是一个多么特别的一集啊。但在我们剖析它之前，今天我们有一位非常特殊的嘉宾。他就是我们自己的萨姆·基弗。大家好。
Welcome, Sam. Sam is at the table in the recording booth with us. We are so excited to have you on the podcast today. We could not have celebrated this episode without you, but maybe we should share the bittersweet reason why you are a guest on the show and not engineering the show today. And some of you listening might know this, Sam, you shared on your Instagram. But after we recorded our last episode, the Target, Series XM did a big round of layoffs and Sam and some of the other Earwolf employees were let go. Yeah, I didn't make the cut. Oh, you make my cut.
欢迎，萨姆。萨姆和我们一起坐在录音间的桌旁。我们非常高兴你能来到今天的播客。没有你，我们无法庆祝这一集，但也许我们应该分享一下苦乐参半的原因——为什么你今天是节目的嘉宾，而不是今天的音频工程师。听节目的有些人可能知道这件事，萨姆，你在Instagram上分享过。但在我们录制上一集《塔吉特》之后，SiriusXM公司进行了一轮大规模裁员，萨姆和其他一些Earwolf的员工被解雇了。是的，我没能留下来。噢，你在我这里留下来了。
Every time. Yes. So we wanted to give a little background for people who may not know how it all works. When we started Office Ladies back in 2019. Yep. That can't be right. Yes, I found it.
每次都这样。是的，所以我们想为那些可能不知道这一切是如何运作的人提供一些背景信息。当我们回到2019年开始制作《办公室女郎》时。是的。那不对吧。是的，我找到了。
It's in my digital clutter. Continue, continue. Okay, well, we signed a deal with Earwulf and when we agreed to work together, part of the deal was that they would give us a recording space and a production team. So we went in for our first day of work and they just introduced us to you, Sam.
它在我的数字杂物堆里。继续，继续。好吧，嗯，我们和Earwolf签了一份协议，当我们同意合作时，协议的一部分是他们会给我们一个录音空间和一个制作团队。所以我们去上班的第一天，他们就把你介绍给我们了，萨姆。
They were like, this is your sound engineer. And then a couple of years ago, Earwulf and its partner Stitcher got bought by SiriusXM. So now it's kind of all under SiriusXM. And they started implementing some changes, like how they closed down the Earwolf recording studio. And then they did layoffs and then the layoffs included you, Sam. And it all took us completely by surprise. I mean, we learned about it when you texted us.
他们说，这是你的录音工程师。然后几年后，Earwolf及其合作伙伴Stitcher被SiriusXM收购了。所以现在它基本上都在SiriusXM旗下。他们开始实施一些改变，比如他们关闭了Earwolf录音室。然后他们进行了裁员，然后裁员名单里包括了你，萨姆。这一切完全让我们措手不及。我的意思是，我们是通过你发给我们的短信才得知这个消息的。
Yeah. I learned about it by surprise too. Yeah, you did. I mean, we were just heartbroken and you know, Sam, I went back into my digital clutter like I do, and you have literally been with Jenna and I from day one. I know. Day one. and I from day one. I know.
是的。我也是突然得知这个消息的。是的，你确实是。我的意思是，我们当时心碎了，你知道的，萨姆，我回到了我的数字杂物堆里，就像我经常做的那样，你从第一天起就一直和珍娜和我在一起。我知道。第一天。和我从第一天起就在一起。我知道。
Day one, I found a video from May 1st, 2019, where I was filming us getting set up in the studio for our first recording, and I met you while videoing. Really? And I have it. I'm gonna show you guys. Oh my gosh. Yeah, ready? Yeah. Angela, I love you for things like this. Yes.
第一天，我找到了一段2019年5月1日的视频，当时我正在拍摄我们在录音室里为第一次录制做准备的情景，我就是在录像时认识你的。真的吗？我有录像。我要给你们看。哦天哪。是的，准备好了吗？是的。安吉拉，我喜欢你这样的人。是的。
That I never clean out my phone videos and photos. Okay, here we go. Here we are. Okay, we are at Earwulf. This is Colin and Cody. Look, office. Jenna, this is our very first time. There's Jenna Fisher.
我从来不清理手机里的视频和照片。好了，我们开始吧。我们在这里。好吧，我们在Earwolf。这是科林和科迪。看，办公室。珍娜，这是我们第一次。那是珍娜·费舍。
I'm very busy, I'm preparing for a podcast. Look at all your notes. Excuse me, excuse me. See, I always say Jenna's who you wanna sit next to in chemistry class. Okay, and. Sam. Sam. Oh, wow. Oh wow. Make sure we sound normal, Jenna. So that's great. Hi. Hi, good morning. Hi, how are you? Hi. Okay, bye. Put a filter on that. Wow. That was the first time. You swung over and you like had to say, yeah, it's Sam. And I said, oh, hi, Sam. Okay. I mean, May 1st, 2019.
我很忙，我在准备播客。看你所有的笔记。打扰一下，打扰一下。看，我总是说珍娜是你在化学课上最想挨着坐的人。好了，还有。萨姆。萨姆。哦，哇。确保我们的声音听起来很正常，珍娜。太棒了。嗨。嗨，早上好。嗨，你好吗？嗨。好吧，拜拜。给那个加个滤镜。哇。那是第一次。你走过来不得不说，是的，我是萨姆。然后我说，哦，嗨，萨姆。好吧。我的意思是，2019年5月1日。
That's incredible. I mean, you're just such a big part of our office ladies family. We could not celebrate this milestone without you. Oh, thank you. And I have to say, I'm really upset and gutted that we're gonna finish this thing that we started together and you're not gonna be with us.
这太不可思议了。我的意思是，你是我们办公室女郎大家庭的重要成员。没有你，我们无法庆祝这个里程碑。哦，谢谢。而且我得说，对于我们要完成我们一起开始的这件事而你却不能和我们在一起，我真的感到难过和心碎。
I know, me too. Oh, me too. Yeah. It's um... It just doesn't even seem like. It's, it's just... It's just... Yeah. It's just...
我知道，我也是。哦，我也是。是的。这……这简直让人难以置信……这只是……这只是……是的。这只是……
Yeah. Yep. I've been trying to look at it from the positive point of view and see what doors it opens and that whole thing, but currently I am still in the anger stage of the grief process. So yes. Yes, I feel that. It's brutal. Yeah. Yeah, well, you know, we started our Office Ladies Network,
是的。没错。我一直试图从积极的角度来看待它，看看它会打开什么门之类的，但目前我仍处于悲伤过程的愤怒阶段。所以是的。是的，我感同身受。太残酷了。是的。是的，你知道的，我们创办了办公室女郎网络，
but it's still under the umbrella of SiriusXM, but I really do hope, Sam, that there's gonna be a way that we're gonna work together again. Me too, I have the feeling we're not done. We're not done, I really believe that. And I did, Sam, I did have to make you a scrapbook. Okay. It's from Jenna and I.
但它仍然在SiriusXM的羽翼之下，但我真的希望，萨姆，将来会有办法让我们再次合作。我也是，我有种预感，我们还没结束。我们还没结束，我真的相信这一点。萨姆，我确实不得不为你制作一本剪贴簿。好的。这是珍娜和我送的。
It's from Angela. Who's a physical scrapbook? It is, well first of all- Sam, it's from Angela. Yeah, okay. Okay. It's amazing. You can tell by the level of craftsmanship that I probably did it, but it is from Jenna and I. And you know what, I could not believe
这是安吉拉送的。谁做了一本实体剪贴簿？是的，首先——萨姆，这是安吉拉送的。是的，好吧。好吧。太棒了。从工艺水平可以看出这可能是我做的，但这是珍娜和我一起送的。你知道吗，我简直不敢相信
how many photos I had of us. Really? Yeah. It's been four years and you can look at it later. You also get Office Ladies tote bag. But that's for you. Anyway, we had a lot of wonderful memories and I just know that this isn't goodbye. Oh wow.
我有那么多我们俩的照片。真的吗？是的。已经四年了，你以后可以看看它。你还会得到一个办公室女郎手提袋。但那是给你的。总之，我们有很多美好的回忆，我知道这不是永别。哦，哇。
You're going to make me cry. Thank you guys. Thank you so much for this. Yeah. I forgot how much I wore sweatpants to work. You did. You did. You got a real comfortable period there.
你这是要弄哭我啊。谢谢你们。非常感谢你们送这个。是的。我都忘了我以前工作时穿了多少次运动裤。你确实穿了。你确实穿了。你有一段非常舒适的时期。
And you know what? I also love your dog, Raman made it. Oh, yes. Raman's in the book too. Oh, God. Yeah. And I have a whole chapter called The Pandemic in there. And it's just all Zoom photos.
你知道吗？我也很喜欢你的狗，拉面也登场了。哦，是的。拉面也在书里。哦，天哪。是的。我在里面还有一个专门的章节叫“大流行”。里面全都是Zoom截图。
Thank you. Well, Sam, we thought a really fun thing to do for our 200th episode. And as just to honor your time on the show is to interview you. I'm so nervous and so excited. Okay. So our top of show today, we're going to kick things off with our favorite question. We shared that you were assigned to us. Yes. So our top of show today, we're going to kick things off with our favorite question. We shared that you were assigned to us, right? But how did you get your job on Office Ladies from your side?
谢谢。好吧，萨姆，我们觉得为我们的第200集做一件非常有趣的事，也是为了纪念你在节目中的时光，那就是采访你。我既紧张又兴奋。好的。所以我们节目的开头，我们要以我们最喜欢的问题拉开序幕。我们分享过你是被指派给我们的。是的。所以我们节目的开头，我们要以我们最喜欢的问题拉开序幕。我们分享过你是被指派给我们的，对吧？但从你的角度来看，你是如何得到《办公室女郎》这份工作的？
How did that happen? So I think it was Paul Scheer had mentioned that you guys were coming to be on our network before anything was announced. He had mentioned it just offhand and I piped up and I was like, Hey, I love the office. wanted to like put my stake my claim in it immediately and he was like, alright cool and just like when I went out With his day, but Colin overheard that and then when it was time to record the pilot put me in What are some of your favorite memories from your time on Office Ladies or a behind the scenes moment that you would like to share? All right. Now I'm literally taking a page out of your book, consulting my phone full
那是怎么发生的？所以我想是保罗·谢尔在任何事情宣布之前就提到过你们要来我们的网络。他随口提了一下，我插话道：“嘿，我喜欢《办公室》。”我立刻想宣示主权，他说：“好吧，酷。”然后就像我和他一起出去……但科林无意中听到了，然后在录制试播集的时候把我安排进去了。关于你在《办公室女郎》的时光，你有哪些最喜欢的记忆，或者你想分享的幕后时刻？好吧。现在我真的是照搬你的套路，查阅我手机里满载
of notes that I took for this. I had such a hard time picking behind the scenes things that were each episode recording was such a fun, magical thing. And it's rare. I think it's an office quote. Isn't it, Andy? Who's like, it's, how come you never can know that you're in the special times while you're in them? Right, right, yes. This was one of those rare moments where every episode we recorded, I was aware that it was special and was magical and was present during it and was recording it in my brain.
为这次采访做的笔记的文件夹。我很难挑出幕后花絮，因为每一集的录制都是如此有趣、神奇的事情。这很罕见。我想这是《办公室》的一句台词。不是吗，安迪？谁说过，为什么你在身处特别时刻的时候，永远不会知道自己正身处其中？对，对，是的。这是一个罕见的时刻，我们录制的每一集，我都意识到它是特别的、神奇的，并且在这个过程中全情投入，把它记录在我的大脑里。
It's like, this is a really special thing we're doing. So, hold on, I have, If you guys put your headphones on, if you can play the clip that says Jenna and Angela post first episode, this is... What? You're coming in with audio clips? Oh my God, I love it! So this is you guys, like, two minutes after recording the very first episode of The Office of the Beast. That video that I just filmed, that's right after that.
就像是，我们正在做一件非常特别的事情。所以，等等，我有，如果你戴上耳机，如果你能播放标有“珍娜和安吉拉录制第一集后”的剪辑，这是……什么？你带着音频剪辑来了？哦，天哪，我太喜欢了！所以这是你们俩，在录制《办公室》第一集大约两分钟后……我刚才拍的那段视频，就是那个时候之后的。
Okay, yeah, exactly. I'm glad to have that behind us I know I hope it's okay they said they can there's so much there I know they'll carve it up and then if we need to come in and do some bumpers or whatever yeah we'll get there we'll get there I'm glad to have it out of our system And I was in my head about it too. It was looming there for me. It's so hard because there's so much to cover and, you know. Oh my goodness, I'm very cold in here.
好的，是的，完全正确。很高兴把这个抛在脑后了我知道，我希望没问题，他们说他们可以，里面有那么多内容，我知道他们会剪辑一下，然后如果我们需要进来做一些转场或者别的什么，是的，我们会搞定的，我们会搞定的很高兴把它从我们的系统中排解出去了。我对此也有些胡思乱想。它对我来说就像个阴影。这太难了，因为有太多内容要讲，而且，你知道的。哦天哪，我这里非常冷。
I just got super, it just like went up a notch. It wasn't. I wasn't. Yeah. Is there ever been a more us audio clip? Yeah, so the episode, if you end, it immediately ends with you guys going negative, being like, like, they couldn't get that out. Like, I couldn't get that out fast enough.
我刚刚变得超级冷，它就像是升了一级。不是这样的。我不是这样的。是的。有没有比这更像我们的音频剪辑了？是的，所以这一集，如果你结束的话，它立即以你们俩开始消极、觉得诸如“他们不可能把那个弄掉”之类的话结束。就像，我没能足够快地把那个弄出来。
I hope that was all right. Also, Angela's starving. I'm eating. I'm eating. Yes. Before we record ever. In almost all the clips I brought, you're eating. I'm so sorry.
我希望一切都好。另外，安吉拉饿了。我在吃东西。我在吃东西。是的。在我们录制之前。在我带来的几乎所有剪辑中，你都在吃东西。我很抱歉。
The minute we stop, I eat. In front of me right now, I have cheese, cas brought, you're eating. I'm so sorry. The minute we stop, I eat in front of me right now. I have cheese, cashews, and cranberries. Oh gosh, that is hilarious. And I am just being so my negative self. Like, well, I don't know. There's probably nothing there, but it's out. I mean, I got it out of me.
我们一停下来，我就吃。此时此刻我面前有奶酪、腰果……你都在吃。我很抱歉。我们一停下来，我就吃。此时此刻我面前有奶酪、腰果和蔓越莓。哦天哪，太搞笑了。而我却表现得那么消极。就像，嗯，我不知道。可能没什么东西，但它出来了。我的意思是，我把它从我体内排解出去了。
Yeah. But what I really liked is you can tell how far you guys have come as podcasters, like just your insecurities in that is fascinating to me, considering now you do them and you're like, that was good. Like you have a solid, like, you know, if something was good or you'll do it and you go, that was bad. That was bad. I got to do that again.
是的。但我真正喜欢的是，你能看出你们作为播客主持人已经走了多远，就像你们当时的那些不安全感对我来说太迷人了，考虑到现在你们做播客时会说，那很好。就像你们有一个扎实的标准，你知道，如果某事很好，或者你们做完后会说，那很糟糕。那太糟糕了。我得重做一遍。
During those first ones, you would do it and go, is this good? Cause there's no one to tell you whether or not it's good. There's no audience to bounce it off of. You are our audience. Yeah, exactly. Oh man. because there's no one to tell you whether or not it's good. There's no audience to bounce it off of. Yeah. You are our audience. Yeah, exactly. Oh man, you know, as I was looking for that video
在头几集里，你们做完会问，这好吗？因为没有人告诉你它究竟好不好。没有观众可以作为反馈。你们就是我们的观众。是的，完全是这样。哦天哪。因为没有人告诉你它究竟好不好。没有观众可以作为反馈。是的。你们就是我们的观众。是的，完全是这样。哦天哪，你知道的，当我寻找那段
of when we first met, I found emails from you that were just titled giggling. Oh yeah. And it's just audio of us losing it. Speaking of which, if you'll play the clip entitled Jenna Angela Fluffernutters. Oh no! Oh no!
我们初次相遇的视频时，我找到了你发给我的电子邮件，主题只是“咯咯笑”。哦，是的。里面只有我们笑疯了的音频。说到这儿，如果你能播放标有“珍娜·安吉拉的棉花糖夹心饼干”的剪辑！哦，不！哦，不！
Oh no! Clip entitled Jenna Angela fluffernutters All right, we have to pause while my friend gets it together My first fluffernutter was in Connecticut. Sorry. I'm sorry. Am I the only one? Sam, please. Sam, please. Yeah.
哦，不！标有“珍娜·安吉拉的棉花糖夹心饼干”的剪辑。好吧，等我朋友平复一下情绪，我们得暂停一下。我的第一个棉花糖夹心饼干是在康涅狄格州吃的。对不起。我很抱歉。我是唯一的一个吗？萨姆，求你了。萨姆，求你了。是的。
Yeah, those behind the scene moments killed me when you would get on a laughing tear. The stuff we had to cut from the episode, just we didn't have time for it, that stuff always killed me. Oh my gosh. I love that. Well, just we didn't have time for it. That stuff always killed me. Oh my gosh. I love that. Well, Sam, do you have a favorite episode that we broke down?
是的，每当你们笑得停不下来的时候，那些幕后时刻简直要了我的命。我们不得不从单集里剪掉的内容，只是因为我们没有时间播出，那些内容总是让我笑死。哦天哪。我太喜欢了。好吧，只是我们没有时间播出。那些内容总是让我笑死。哦天哪。我太喜欢了。好吧，萨姆，我们剖析过的单集里，你最喜欢哪一集？
A favorite, I guess, what would that be? A non behind the scenes, but like an episode moment? I think it was episode three or four that we re-recorded. Oh, we, yes. Healthcare, we re-recorded three different times. Yes. And we used pieces of each one. It was the Frankenstein episode.
最喜欢的一集，我想，那会是什么？不是幕后花絮，而是某一集的某个时刻？我想是我们重新录制的第三集或第四集。哦，我们，是的。医疗保险，我们重新录制了三次。是的。我们用了每一集的部分片段。那是弗兰肯斯坦那一集。
Yes. Hold on, if you'll play, uh, Jenna Angela confess healthcare. Oh, no. This, this killed me. I found this. Should we confess what happened with the healthcare episode, Angela? Should we confess it? No. All right, we'll just move on then.
是的。等等，如果你能播放，呃，“珍娜和安吉拉坦白医疗保险”。哦，不。这个，这个笑死我了。我找到了这个。我们要坦白医疗保险那一集发生了什么吗，安吉拉？我们要坦白吗？不。好吧，那我们就继续吧。
No. If what you mean is that we listened to it and didn't like it, so we're redoing it, no. All right. No, we're perfect. I like how quickly I came to that. Yeah, exactly. I didn't even have to think it up. Like, nope. Nope. Okay, Sam, just like the cast and crew on The Office, you know, I found those questions
不。如果你的意思是说我们听了之后不喜欢，所以我们要重做，不是的。好吧。不，我们很完美。我喜欢我得出这个结论的速度。是的，完全正确。我甚至都不用去编造它。就像，不。不。好吧，萨姆，就像《办公室》里的演员和剧组人员一样，你知道的，我在通告单的背面
on the back of the call sheet. I love them so much. Well, we want to ask you, The Office Cast and Crew, call sheet questions. Great. Lay it on me. Number one, what was your first entertainment job? First entertainment job was doing sound for the Riot Comedy Festival in 2007. It was a short-lived comedy festival that ran downtown for two or three years that my friend Abby put on.
发现了那些问题。我太喜欢它们了。好吧，我们要问你，《办公室》演员和剧组人员的通告单问题。太棒了。尽管问吧。第一题，你的第一份娱乐行业工作是什么？第一份娱乐行业工作是2007年在暴动喜剧节上做音响。那是一个短命的喜剧节，在市中心举办了两三年，是我朋友艾比办的。
And one of the shows on there was Comedy Bang Bang, which afterwards was how I met them and how I got my job at Earwoolf. Wow. Okay, number two, do you speak any other languages? I don't speak any other languages. And I know this because Duolingo is very hostile to me about it. Hold on a minute. We'll show you guys.
其中一个演出是《喜剧大爆炸》，演出结束后，我就是通过那个认识了他们，并在Earwolf得到了这份工作。哇。好的，第二题，你会说其他语言吗？我不会说其他语言。我知道这一点，因为多邻国对此对我很不友好。等一会儿。我们给你们看看。
Do you keep getting props? Like, I, okay. Tell me this isn't the most hostile email you've ever gotten. This is because I skipped a week. I skipped a week. This is because I skipped a week in Duolingo. Okay. What does it say? Read it out loud.
你一直在收到道具吗？就像，我，好吧。告诉我这不是你收到的最具敌意的电子邮件。这是因为我漏了一周。我漏了一周。这是因为我在多邻国漏了一周。好吧。它上面写了什么？大声读出来。
How do you say quitter in Spanish? Yeah, that's the header of the email. How hostile is that? And I like that you wrote back, sorry, that was harsh. No, that's them. That's the body of the email. Yeah, that's Duolingo texting me. Yeah. Oh my gosh. So no, I don't speak another language in Duolingo won't let me forget that. Wow. Number three, what's a place you've been to that you loved?
你在西班牙语里怎么说“逃兵”？是的，那是邮件标题。这多有敌意啊？我喜欢你回信说：“对不起，刚才太严厉了。”不，那是它们。那是邮件正文。是的，那是多邻国发给我的短信。是的。哦天哪。所以不，我不会说其他语言，多邻国不会让我忘记这一点。哇。第三题，你去过哪个让你非常喜欢的地方？
I just went to Brussels in November and went to Bruges. I remember you talking about those. And it was perfect. It was little cobblestone streets and it was perfect. I love it. Love that. And what do you like to do on the weekends? On the weekends, you can usually find me at the music festivals volunteering with End Overdose.
我11月刚去了布鲁塞尔，还去了布鲁日。我记得你谈起过那些地方。那里太完美了。那里有小小的鹅卵石街道，一切都完美极了。我喜欢。太喜欢了。你周末喜欢做什么？在周末，你通常可以找到我在音乐节上做“终结过量吸毒”组织的志愿者。
It's a group that gives out Narcan for reversing opioid overdoses and just trying to get the information out. I always see you post about that and you just have such a heart for others and I just love that about you so much. Okay, last question from the call sheet. Favorite midnight snack? Midnight snack would be Indian food. Oh yeah? At midnight? What specifically? How do you sleep well? I sleep, my sleep schedule is horrific and I'm aware these two are related. You Indian food digesting in your stomach at midnight. I'll get up and order have Indian food delivered. It'll get there at one in the morning. Oh my gosh. Yeah. It's brutal. Does it put you back to sleep? Eventually. Okay. But no, it's definitely an upper. That I was not expecting.
这是一个分发纳洛酮（用于逆转阿片类药物过量）的组织，旨在传播相关信息。我总是看到你发这方面的动态，你对他人充满了爱心，我太喜欢你这一点了。好的，通告单的最后一个问题。最喜欢的午夜零食？午夜零食会是印度菜。哦，是吗？在半夜？具体是什么？你怎么能睡得着？我睡觉，我的睡眠时间简直糟糕透顶，而且我知道这两者是有关联的。你在半夜吃印度菜在胃里消化。我会起床订外卖送印度菜。凌晨一点送到。哦天哪。是的。太残酷了。它能让你重新入睡吗？最终会的。好吧。不过不，它绝对是个兴奋剂。那是我没料到的。
I wasn't either. I was going to say cereal, but lamb tiki marsala? Yeah. All right. I wanna share one of my favorite behind the scenes with you, Sam, is early on when we would edit episodes, Angela and I would come in together with our notes, with our little sack lunches, and we would all cram into your editing day. That's right. And those few hours on those days are just some of my favorite memories from doing this podcast.
我也没料到。我本想说麦片，但却是黄油鸡？是的。好吧。萨姆，我想和你分享我最喜欢的幕后花絮之一，那就是早期我们在剪辑剧集时，安吉拉和我带着笔记和自带的小纸袋午餐一起来，我们都会挤进你的剪辑室。没错。在那几天里的那几个小时，简直是我制作这个播客最美好的回忆。
Honestly, mine too. Yeah. We would laugh and… We would laugh so hard and we would be, you know, there was no extra tables. One time there wasn't even enough chairs. One of us was on the floor and it kind of reminded me of those early days in like college where you all hung out in someone's dorm room.
说实话，我也是。是的。我们会笑，而且……我们会笑得前仰后合，而且你会知道，没有多余的桌子。有一次甚至连椅子都不够。我们其中一个人坐在地上，这让我想起了大学里那种大家都挤在某人宿舍里的早期日子。
We would eat our lunches in our laps, whatever they were. We had to balance them in our laps, plus our notes. And we were in a room that was, I don't know, four by six. It was the size of a very small walk-in closet. Yeah. Yeah. And it was freezing. Yes. Freezing. Yes. Your wolf was freezing.
我们将午餐放在膝盖上吃，不管那是什么。我们必须把它们连同笔记一起平衡在膝盖上。而且我们在一个房间里，我不知道，四乘六英尺。它只有一个非常小的步入式衣帽间那么大。是的。是的。而且冷得要命。是的。冷得要命。是的。Earwolf里面冷极了。
We have many photos of me and Angela in like full winter. Yeah. Yep. And like hoodies and beanies and stuff. Yeah. Yeah. And mittens. But you know, that was before the pandemic, before everybody discovered Zoom. Now we edit on Zoom, but man, I miss those times. And that was, you guys changed up like how a lot of us edit it.
我们有很多我和安吉拉穿着厚重冬装的照片。是的。没错。比如连帽衫、毛线帽之类的。是的。是的，还有连指手套。但你知道，那是在大流行之前，在每个人都发现Zoom之前。现在我们在Zoom上剪辑，天哪，我怀念那些时光。而且，你们改变了我们很多人剪辑的方式。
Up until then, podcasts we just pretty much recorded and there was, I don't know, two or three edits and we'd turn them around. It was a pretty quick process. But this show really changed the way a lot of us edit at Earwool. Wow, it was cool, because we would edit in real time with you.
在此之前，播客基本上就是录制下来，然后有，我不知道，两三次剪辑，我们就会交稿。那是一个相当快的流程。但这个节目确实改变了我们很多人在Earwolf剪辑的方式。哇，这太酷了，因为我们会和你实时剪辑。
We tried emailing you notes and thoughts and it was just like a mess. Yeah, it just worked better for you to go put this here and point at it. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, Sam, thank you so much for being on our 200th episode. Of course.
我们曾试图通过电子邮件把笔记和想法发给你，结果简直一团糟。是的，你把这个放在这里并指出来，这样效果更好。是的。是的。哦，萨姆，非常感谢你能来参加我们的第200集。当然。
And thank you for everything you've done for Office Ladies. And for everybody who has not listened to Sam's podcast, Enemy in Paris, you need to check it out. It is my new favorite, like, it's hilarious. It's my new favorite, like,
谢谢你为《办公室女郎》所做的一切。对于所有还没听过萨姆的播客《艾米丽在巴黎之敌》的人，你们得去听听。这是我新的最爱，简直太搞笑。这是我新的最爱，就像……
it's hilarious. It's my new favorite, like, it's hilarious. It's hilarious. It's hilarious. It's hilarious. It's hilarious. It's hilarious.
简直太搞笑。简直太搞笑。简直太搞笑。简直太搞笑。简直太搞笑。简直太搞笑。简直太搞笑。
It's hilarious. It's hilarious. It's hilarious. It's hilarious. It's hilarious. It's hilarious. It's hilarious. It's hilarious.
简直太搞笑。简直太搞笑。简直太搞笑。简直太搞笑。简直太搞笑。简直太搞笑。简直太搞笑。简直太搞笑。
It's hilarious. It's hilarious. It's hilarious. It's hilarious. It's hilarious. It's hilarious. It's hilarious. Oh, well, that's the goal is we don't want anyone to have to watch the show. Ideally. You don't want to have to watch it again. Yeah. That is hilarious. But it is, if you love to hate watch Emily in Paris, like we do, and we would always talk about it, this is the podcast for you. Yeah. But I love your opening song. I love how you guys describe the scenes.
简直太搞笑。简直太搞笑。简直太搞笑。简直太搞笑。简直太搞笑。简直太搞笑。简直太搞笑。哦，好吧，我们的目标是不让任何人必须看这部剧。理想情况下。你不需要再看一遍。是的。这太搞笑了。但如果你像我们一样喜欢带着吐槽的心态看《艾米丽在巴黎》，而且我们总是讨论它，这就是适合你的播客。是的。不过我喜欢你的开场曲。我喜欢你们描述场景的方式。
I love your deep dives. I, I- Which are heavily lifted from this show. Oh my gosh. I mean, you guys are very entertaining. I love your deep dives. Uh-huh. Which are heavily lifted from this show. Oh my gosh. I mean, you guys are very entertaining. I love your co-host. It's great. Yeah, back to you.
我喜欢你们的深度挖掘。我，我——这些大部分都是从这个节目里抄来的。哦天哪。我的意思是，你们非常具有娱乐精神。我喜欢你们的深度挖掘。嗯哼。这些大部分都是从这个节目里抄来的。哦天哪。我的意思是，你们非常具有娱乐精神。我喜欢你们的主持搭档。太棒了。是的，回到你们。
Everybody go listen to it. Go listen to it. We're going to put a swipe up in our Instagram stories. Sam also brought us… Yes, I brought you guys. So we have official merch. There's an episode where this woman, this American actress comes to Paris and only refers to Emily as bucket hat Yeah, and says Bonsoir bucket hats. So we have Bonsoir bucket hats. It's perfect. I love it so much
大家都去听听吧。去听听吧。我们将在我们的Instagram快拍中放置一个上滑链接。萨姆还给我们带来了……是的，我给你们带了。所以我们有官方周边。有一集里，这个女人，这个美国女演员来到巴黎，只把艾米丽称为“渔夫帽”，是的，还说“Bonsoir，渔夫帽”。所以我们有“Bonsoir渔夫帽”。太完美了，我太喜欢了。
I can't wait to wear it. I'm gonna wear it on my walks. I'm gonna wear it on my hike I'm gonna take a picture of us in it Jenna great And I just wanted to say my time here Triggered something very special inside me. You two took a very simple concept of a recap show and made something extremely special, something extremely rare, something that bonds people. That's the thing that all podcast companies desperately want, that they foam at the mouth over that they can't recreate.
我迫不及待想戴上它了。我要在散步时戴着它。我要在徒步时戴着它。我要拍一张我们戴着它的照片，珍娜，太棒了。我只想说，我在这里的时光触发了我内心非常特别的东西。你们俩拿一个非常简单的重温秀的概念，做出了极其特殊、极其罕见、能把人们凝聚在一起的东西。这就是所有播客公司都极度渴望、垂涎三尺却无法复制的东西。
And it comes down to the people making it, the time it was made. It takes a very special type of magic to create a show like this and you too did it. I hope you're very proud of yourselves and if you ever doubt that, take a peek into the fan page on Facebook. The community that has rallied behind this podcast is truly incredible and rare and magical. And to that fandom, I just want to say you are seen and you are heard and you are loved. Even when you think nobody sees you, you are seen and you are loved. Even when you think nobody sees you, you are seen and you were loved. I'm just, I don't know how to do the podcast.
这归结于制作它的人，以及它被制作的时代。创作这样一个节目需要一种非常特殊的魔法，而你们两个做到了。我希望你们为自己感到非常骄傲，如果你曾经怀疑这一点，去Facebook的粉丝专页看一眼吧。支持这个播客的社区真的不可思议、罕见而神奇。对于这个粉丝群体，我只想说，你们被看到了，你们被听到了，你们是被爱的。即使你认为没有人看到你，你也是被看到的，你也是被爱的。即使你认为没有人看到你，你也是被看到的，你也是被爱的。我只是，我不知道该怎么做播客了。
It'll be okay. Thank you so much for sharing that. But, but more than that, just thank you for believing in Jen and I, when we had so much self doubt and we were in a whole new space and some people wrote us off right away and you never did. Oh no you guys were had something special right out of the gate. We just love you. Hope you guys are very proud of yourselves. We love you so much. Great. If we can go out in the clip of Jenna and Angela dancing. Oh my gosh. I think you posted this before there was an episode we recorded that just didn't click from the start.
会没事的。非常感谢你分享这些。但是，更重要的是，谢谢你相信珍娜和我，当时我们充满了自我怀疑，我们身处一个全新的空间，有些人立刻就不看好我们，而你从未放弃。哦，不，你们从一开始就有着特别的东西。我们太爱你了。希望你们为自己感到非常骄傲。我们太爱你了。太棒了。如果我们能以珍娜和安吉拉跳舞的剪辑结束。哦天哪。我想你发布这个是在我们录制一集从一开始就不对劲的节目之前。
So you stopped and danced to Taylor Swift for 30 seconds. I remember this, Jenna was in her head and I was like, we gotta get in our body. It was the third one we recorded, but it was the pilot. And because it was the pilot, I suddenly couldn't. You shut down. I did. And I made Sam put on Taylor Swift.
所以你们停下来跳了30秒的泰勒·斯威夫特的舞。我记得这个，珍娜当时思绪万千，我说，我们得让身体动起来。这是我们录制的第三集，但它是试播集。正因为它是试播集，我突然就……你崩溃了。我确实崩溃了。我让萨姆放了泰勒·斯威夫特的歌。
And there's a great Angela cussing in it, which is always funny to me. Oh no. No. Get loose. Hey. Hey. It's just so much pressure to say it.
里面还有一段安吉拉说脏话的精彩片段，这对我来说总是很有趣。哦，不。不。放松。嘿。嘿。说出来压力太大了。
It is. It is. It's so much pressure. I'm fucking terrified, Sam, Sam, Sam, Sam, Sam. Well, I'll see you. This isn't the end. Yeah, this isn't the end. And by the way, I have my cell phone on me. We can make outgoing calls at the studio. Always call me like you've done if you have any Lord of the Rings questions. Or do you remember once you called me?
确实。是的。压力太大了。我他妈的吓坏了，萨姆，萨姆，萨姆，萨姆，萨姆。好吧，回头见。这并不是终点。是的，这并不是终点。顺便说一句，我身上带着手机。我们可以在录音室打外拨电话。如果你有任何关于《指环王》的问题，就像你以前一样随时打电话给我。或者你还记得有一次你给我打电话吗？
I remember once, actually, I do have a favorite memory. I have a favorite show memory. I was in New York and my phone rang and you were on the air and you wanted to know if someplace was the porn capital of the world. And I was like, why would I know this? And they're like, why don't you? Like, it was just... But you did know. Yeah And they're like, why don't you? Like it was- But you did know.
我记得有一次，其实，我确实有一个最喜欢的记忆。我有一个最喜欢的节目记忆。我在纽约，我的电话响了，你在节目直播中，你想知道某个地方是不是世界的色情之都。我当时想，我怎么会知道这个？他们说，你为什么不知道？就像，这只是……但你确实知道。是的。而他们说，你为什么不知道？就像是——但你确实知道。
Yeah, I did. But you did know. It was somewhere- It's in California. It's in like Studio City. Oh yeah, Chatsworth. Yeah. Chatsworth. Yep. Yeah.
是的，我知道。但你确实知道。它在某处——在加利福尼亚。在类似Studio City的地方。哦，是的，查茨沃思。是的。查茨沃思。没错。是的。
That's my favorite. We called you on vacation. Yeah, that's right. That's right. All right, Sam, you'll be our dial-a-friend. All right. I love you guys. Love you so much. Love you too. Guys, we're gonna take a break. We're gonna give Sam some hugs
那是我的最爱。我们在你度假时给你打电话。是的，没错。没错。好吧，萨姆，你将是我们的“给好友打电话”热线。好吧。我爱你们。非常爱你们。我也爱你们。伙计们，我们要休息一下。我们要给萨姆一个拥抱，
and have a good finish to our ugly cry. And then we'll be back to break down Dwight's Christmas. All right. ["Dwight's Christmas Theme"] Hello, we are back and wow, it was really so good to have that moment with Sam. I just loved it. I loved having him on the show so much. And thank you also to the Office Ladies family.
然后好好结束我们那痛哭流涕的时刻。然后我们会回来剖析《德怀特的圣诞节》。好的。["德怀特的圣诞节主题曲"] 嗨，我们回来了，哇，和萨姆一起度过那个时刻感觉真的很棒。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢他在节目里了。同时也感谢办公室女郎大家庭。
A lot of you have reached out to us. And to Sam. And to Sam. And it's meant a lot to all of us. And I know Sam holds all of your messages very dear. Yes. Well, now we are gonna break down Dwight's Christmas. Yep.
你们中的许多人都联系了我们。还有萨姆。还有萨姆。这对我们所有人都意义重大。我知道萨姆把你们所有的信息都铭记在心。是的。好吧，现在我们要剖析《德怀特的圣诞节》。是的。
This is season nine, episode nine, written by Robert Padnick and directed by Charles McDougall. Action. Remember Charles McDougall directed our very first Christmas episode, Yankee Swap, and Greg wanted him to come back to direct the last. Yep. This is the last Christmas for the Dunder Mifflin crew.
这是第九季第九集，由罗伯特·帕德尼克编剧，查尔斯·麦克道尔执导。Action。还记得查尔斯·麦克道尔执导了我们的第一个圣诞节特别集《洋基换礼》，格雷格想让他回来执导最后一集。是的。这是邓德米夫林团队的最后一个圣诞节。
Yes. Here's your summary. It is the eve of Jim's first day at his new job, and everyone in the office realizes they forgot to plan the office Christmas party. They ultimately take Dwight up on his suggestion of a traditional Pennsylvania Dutch Christmas. Meanwhile, in Andy's absence, Pete and Erin bond while watching Die Hard, and Daryl fears that Jim has forgotten his promise to include him in the new business. Yeah, he's really taking that hard.
是的。这是剧情梗概。今天是吉姆新工作第一天的前夕，办公室里的每个人都意识到他们忘记规划办公室圣诞节派对。他们最终采纳了德怀特的建议，举办传统的宾夕法尼亚荷兰式圣诞节。与此同时，在安迪不在的情况下，皮特和艾琳在看《虎胆龙威》时拉近了距离，而达里尔则担心吉姆忘记了他承诺将他纳入新业务的诺言。是的，他对此真的很在意。
So, you know, we jump right into this episode. There is no cold open. There are no opening credits. This is the only episode in the entire series without opening credits. It was a big episode, and I read the shooting draft. A lot more happens, and I think they had to really trim it down.
所以，你知道的，我们直接进入这一集。没有片头冷笑话。也没有片头演职员表。这是整部剧里唯一一集没有片头演职员表的剧集。这是一个大制作的一集，我读了拍摄剧本。发生的事情要多得多，我想他们不得不对其进行大刀阔斧的删减。
Well, we open with Jim and Pam at their desks, and Jim is having second thoughts about the shirt he packed. He's doing that thing where he's nervous about his new job, and that anxiety is being sort of processed through his packing list. Yes, and Dwight comments that Jim's shirt makes him look like a mop. And Pam agrees.
好吧，开场是吉姆和帕姆在他们的办公桌前，吉姆对打包的衬衫产生了犹豫。他在做那种对新工作感到紧张的事情，这种焦虑某种程度上通过他的打包清单表现出来。是的，德怀特评论说吉姆的衬衫让他看起来像个拖把。帕姆也表示赞同。
Pam's like, it kind of does. Pam's like, yeah. This is when Erin realizes, oh my gosh, today is the Christmas party. Angela's like, wait, that can't be right. Kevin is so angry immediately with Angela. Like, how could you do this? And guess who comes to Angela's defense?
帕姆说，确实有点像。帕姆说，是的。就在这时，艾琳意识到，哦天哪，今天是圣诞派对。安吉拉说，等等，这不对吧。凯文立刻对安吉拉非常生气。怎么能这样呢？你猜谁来为安吉拉辩护？
Oscar. Well, yes, because he's basically still trying to gain her forgiveness for his affair with her husband. I'm going to bring it up later, but there is a moment that was in the shooting draft where he slowly gets her favor. Really? Yes. I'll share it in a bit. Well, I will say, in this scene, I really
奥斯卡。好吧，是的，因为他基本上还在试图为他与她丈夫的私情争取她的原谅。我待会儿会提到这一点，但在拍摄剧本中有一个时刻，他慢慢赢得了她的青睐。真的吗？是的。我一会儿分享。好吧，我要说的是，在这个场景中，我真的很
loved the shot of the turkey decoration. Yes. As everyone's realizing that it's the Christmas party. Also, there is a scarecrow behind Erin at reception. Yep. So not only did they forget to plan the Christmas party, they have not taken down any of the Thanksgiving decorations. Exactly.
喜欢火鸡装饰的镜头。是的。当每个人都意识到这是圣诞派对时。此外，在前台艾琳的身后还有一个稻草人。是的。所以他们不仅忘记规划圣诞派对，而且还没有撤掉任何感恩节装饰。没错。
Well, we have some Phyllis Snark, some good old Phyllis Snark. She says, you know what? I knew the party was today, but nobody asked me to plan it, so I didn't. Funny how that works. You know what? That felt very lazy genius to me. I think this is an example of why Kendra said
好吧，我们有一些菲莉丝的讽刺，原汁原味的菲莉丝式讽刺。她说，你知道吗？我知道今天是派对，但没人叫我策划，所以我没策划。有趣的是事情就是这样运作的。你知道吗？我觉得这对我来说非常符合“懒人天才”的作风。我认为这就是肯德拉说
that Phyllis is a lazy genius. Because a lazy genius doesn't plan things they weren't asked to plan, and it's not their job to like you know pick up the pieces of your slack. Phyllis knew this day was coming she was waiting for it. Yeah. Well Meredith thinks they deserve a Christmas party for all the balls they've been busting. I thought Kate Flannery was so funny they've been busting their balls. Nellie says, you know what? Let's get mini cupcakes. This set Kevin off. Oh, this is a famous line that gets quoted all the time.
菲莉丝是个懒人天才的原因。因为懒人天才不会去策划那些没被要求策划的事情，而且收拾你的烂摊子也不是他们的工作。菲莉丝知道这一天会到来，她一直在等它。是的。好吧，梅雷迪思认为鉴于他们一直以来付出的巨大努力，他们理应举办一个圣诞派对。我觉得凯特·弗兰纳里太搞笑了，他们付出了巨大的努力。内莉说，你知道吗？我们买迷你纸杯蛋糕吧。这让凯文爆发了。哦，这是一句经常被引用的名言。
Yeah, Kevin's like, wait, cupcakes are already mini versions of cakes, and now you want to even make the cupcake smaller? Yes. He's very, very angry about it. It makes me laugh every time. I do love a mini cupcake, though. I do, too. I like it even smaller. me laugh every time. I do love a mini cupcake though. I do too.
是的，凯文说，等等，纸杯蛋糕本来就是蛋糕的迷你版，现在你还想把纸杯蛋糕弄得更小？是的。他对此非常非常生气。每次都逗得我哈哈大笑。不过我确实喜欢迷你纸杯蛋糕。我也喜欢。我喜欢更小的。
I like it even smaller. What are those super tiny ones we got one time? Melissa Bakes or something? Remember? Baked by Melissa. Yes! They're even, they're even minier than a mini cupcake. They're literally bite size. But they're so good.
我们有一次买的那些超级小的叫什么？Melissa Bakes还是别的什么？记得吗？Baked by Melissa。是的！它们比迷你纸杯蛋糕还要迷你。它们真的是一口一个的大小。但它们太好吃了。
Someone sent it to us as a thank you. And you and I were so delighted. Yeah, baked by Melissa, everybody. Look it up. Not baked. What did I say? Melissa bakes. Not Melissa bakes.
有人把它作为感谢礼物送给我们。你和我都高兴坏了。是的，Baked by Melissa，大家。去查查。不是Baked。我刚才说什么来着？Melissa Bakes。不是Melissa Bakes。
Baked by Melissa. That's right. It makes a really good gift. I've given it now. Yeah. Better than flowers. And they have gluten-free ones. Just saying.
是Baked by Melissa。没错。这是一个很好的礼物。我现在送过这个了。是的。比花更好。而且他们还有无麸质的。顺便说一句。
Just putting it out there. Dwight has an idea now about the Pennsylvania Dutch Christmas. Jim immediately is like, no, that's it. I'm in. Stanley Pennsylvania Dutch Christmas. Jim immediately is like, no, that's it. I'm in. Stanley wants tropical Christmas. Meredith wants topless Christmas. Creed wants tapas Swissmas. And then he says Spanish tapas and Swissmas hot cocoa. What's so hard to understand? I want you to know there was an extended storyline here.
只是提一下。德怀特现在对宾夕法尼亚荷兰式圣诞节有个主意。吉姆立刻说，不，就这样。我加入。斯坦利想要热带圣诞节。梅雷迪思想要无上装圣诞节。克里德想要西班牙小吃和瑞士圣诞。然后他说西班牙小吃和瑞士圣诞热可可。这有什么难理解的？我想让你们知道这里有一个延伸的故事线。
About tapas Swissmas? No. About topless Christmas? About what? You're going to just list them all off? I know. Okay. The storyline here was extended. Angela actually holds a conference room meeting. We know she has an emergency one later in the episode, but she decides right here to audition everyone who has a real idea for a Christmas party.
关于西班牙小吃和瑞士圣诞？不。关于无上装圣诞节？关于什么？你打算把它们全都列举出来吗？我知道。好吧。这里的 storylines 延伸了。安吉拉实际上开了一个会议室会议。我们知道她在这一集后段有一个紧急会议，但她就在这里决定试镜每一个对圣诞派对有真正想法的人。
And it's in the deleted scenes. It's going to start with Dwight giving a presentation, then Kevin. Kevin, you have to imagine she makes this announcement and they only have a few minutes to get their ideas together. But Kevin comes in with an easel and a huge elaborate poster where in one picture is just Kevin and his boxer shorts and a t-shirt. And then there's an overlay he drops over and it's a Santa suit. And then the next person is Meredith and she just walks in and she lifts up her shirt and
这在被删减的片段里。开场是德怀特做演示，然后是凯文。凯文，你得想象她发布了这个通知，而他们只有几分钟时间把他们的想法凑到一起。但凯文带着一个画架和一个巨大的精心制作的海报走了进来，海报上一张照片里只有凯文穿着拳击短裤和T恤。然后是一个他放下覆盖的图层，是一套圣诞老人服装。然后下一个人是梅雷迪思，她直接走进来掀起衬衫，
she has Santa hats over her boobs. Oh my gosh. I know. And we also learned a little bit of how Angela would run a meeting. There's some snark, there's some insults, and there's rules. It's in deleted scenes. Let's hear it. And that is why this Christmas should be a Pennsylvania Dutch Christmas. Duncan. Thank you Dwight. We will take your idea into consideration. Please do. Thank you very much. Dwight for Christmas party. Sorry but that looked
她的胸部上贴着圣诞老人帽。哦天哪。我懂的。我们还了解到一些安吉拉开会的方式。有一些讽刺，有一些侮辱，还有规矩。这在被删减的片段里。我们听听。这就是为什么这个圣诞节应该是一个宾夕法尼亚荷兰式圣诞节。下一个。谢谢你，德怀特。我们会考虑你的建议。请务必考虑。非常感谢。德怀特为了圣诞派对。抱歉，但在我看来那
like a cat's butt to me. Next! Good luck Chump. Thanks. Hope I get it. Kevin? Yeah? Santa! He right. Santa? Kevin? It'll make Christmas a ho-ho-home run. Once again, displays of support are not needed. Booze are okay.
看起来像猫的屁股。下一个！祝你好运，笨蛋。谢谢。希望我能选上。凯文？什么？圣诞老人！他说的对。圣诞老人？凯文？它会让圣诞节成为一个本垒打。再说一次，不需要展示支持。嘘声是可以的。
Next! Oh! Oh. Thank you. Lots of good ideas here. What was that? Did you hear the moment when I sounded very Southern and all of that?
下一个！哦！哦。谢谢。这里有很多好主意。那是什么？你听到我听起来非常南方口音的那个时刻了吗？
No, when? I heard it so loud. When Angela Martin goes, that looked like a cat's butt to me. Oh, yeah. Well, Angela does call an emergency party planning committee, and Pam tells Jim basically, I'm going to get you the Dwight's Pennsylvania Dutch Christmas. Sort of like it's going to be her going away present to Jim.
没有，什么时候？我听得很清楚。当安吉拉·马丁说，在我看来那看起来像猫的屁股。哦，是的。好吧，安吉拉确实召集了一次紧急派对规划委员会，帕姆基本上告诉吉姆，我要为你争取到德怀特的宾夕法尼亚荷兰式圣诞节。有点像是她送给吉姆的告别礼物。
Right. Well, you know, everyone in the bullpen has listened to Dwight really push his idea. And Pete says, I hope German terrorists don't take over the Christmas party or he'll have to go all John McClain on them. And Aaron corrects him and says, I think you mean John McCain.
没错。好吧，你知道的，起居室里的每个人都听着德怀特极力推销他的想法。皮特说，我希望德国恐怖分子不要接管圣诞派对，否则他不得不像约翰·麦克莱恩那样对付他们。艾琳纠正他说，我想你的意思是约翰·麦凯恩。
And he's like, no, wait, have you not seen Die Hard? Aaron has not seen Die Hard. Erin has not seen Die Hard. Pete and Kevin cannot believe this. Cannot believe it. And this is when we find out that Pete, I guess in his youth on a dare from his brother, has memorized the entire movie of Die Hard and he starts reciting it for Erin.
然后他说，不，等等，你没看过《虎胆龙威》吗？艾琳没看过《虎胆龙威》。艾琳没看过《虎胆龙威》。皮特和凯文简直不敢相信。简直不敢相信。这就是我们发现的时候，皮特在年轻时由于他兄弟的挑衅，背熟了整部《虎胆龙威》的电影，他开始为艾琳背诵台词。
Do you have a movie that you know like that? When Harry Met Sally. Really? Oh, that's a good one. Because when I used to drive from my college to my house and back, it was about a three-hour drive. I used an old cassette recorder and I recorded the movie when Harry Met Sally, and I would listen to it in the car. Because you didn't have a radio.
你有没有哪部电影是这样熟记于心的？《当哈利遇到莎莉》。真的吗？哦，那是个好电影。因为我以前从我的大学开车回家，来回大约需要三个小时。我用了一个旧盒式录音机录下了电影《当哈利遇到莎莉》，我会在车里听它。因为你没有收音机。
Yes. So I would listen to two things on that drive. I would listen to it in the car. Because you didn't have a radio. Yes. And so I would listen to two things on that drive. I would listen to the Les Mis soundtrack, and I would listen to When Harry Met Sally, the movie. You would hit play on your tape recorder. Yes, in the passenger seat. That is so cute. And it would keep me entertained. That is so cute.
是的。所以在开车时我会听两样东西。我会把它们在车里放着。因为那时候还没有收音机。对。所以我开车时会听两样东西。我会听《悲惨世界》的原声带，还会听电影《当哈利遇到莎妮》。你会在录音机上按播放键。对，就在副驾驶座上。太可爱了。这能让我觉得不无聊。太可爱了。
Do you have one? I mean, you know, I know a few movies like that, because I used to just be such a nerd, and I'd watch movies over and over again. But one that I know almost every line to is Top Gun. Really? You've seen it that many times? I guess so.
你有这样的电影吗？我的意思是，我知道一些那样的电影，因为我以前是个超级书呆子，会把同一部电影看了一遍又一遍。但我几乎能背出每一句台词的电影是《壮志凌云》。真的吗？你看过那么多遍？我想是的。
Wow. It wasn't, like, intentional. But I watched it with the kids, and they were so annoyed with me, because I kept saying the lines, just to walk in the park, Mav. They're like, Mom. Ha ha ha. Well, we got a fan question from Graceann S.
哇。这倒不是说我刻意去看的。不过我是和孩子们一起看的，他们对我烦透了，因为我一直在背台词。“只是去公园散散步，小牛（Mav）。”他们就说：“妈——哈哈哈哈。”好吧，我们收到了来自路易斯安那州拉斐尔市的格蕾丝安·S（Graceann S.）的粉丝提问。
in Lafayette, Louisiana. My birth city, Lafayette. I knew you would like this. Graceann said, I have a question about Pete's storyline, knowing all the lines from Die Hard. Did this come from any of the writer's experiences or any stories they heard?
我的出生地，拉斐尔。我知道你会喜欢这个。格蕾丝安说，我有一个关于皮特（Pete）故事线的问题，他知道《虎胆龙威》的所有台词。这取材于某个编剧的亲身经历，还是他们听过什么故事？
I was curious about that too. And you know, we reached out to the writer of this episode, Robert Padnick, he was fantastic. And he shared with us that this story likely came from his personal love of Die Hard. He said he remembers once pitching a plot line where Dwight as the office Santa crawls through the air ducts to deliver a present,
我也对此很好奇。你知道的，我们联系了这集的编剧罗伯特·帕德尼克（Robert Padnick），他太棒了。他跟我们分享说，这个情节很可能源于他本人对《虎胆龙威》的热爱。他说他记得自己曾推销过这样一个情节：德怀特（Dwight）作为办公室的圣诞老人，为了送礼物而在通风管道里爬行，
remember in Die Hard where he's crawling through the air ducts? And he said, you know what? No one really loved the idea, so it didn't happen. But maybe the Pete storyline was his attempt to jam Die Hard in there somewhere. And he also wanted me to share with everyone, it's a really good movie, exclamation point. Well, I love it.
还记得《虎胆龙威》里他在通风管道里爬的情节吗？他说，你知道吗？其实没人在意这个创意，所以就没拍成。但也许皮特的这条故事线就是他试图把《虎胆龙威》塞进剧里的尝试。他还想让我告诉大家，这是一部非常棒的电影，感叹号。好吧，我太喜欢了。
Same. You know, there's a big debate. Is Die Hard a Christmas movie? Yeah, I've heard about this. Well, I did a little deep dive on this question. On the big debate? Yes. OK.
我也是。你知道的，现在有个巨大的争论。《虎胆龙威》到底算不算是一部圣诞电影？对，我听说过这事。好吧，我针对这个问题做了一点深度研究。针对这个巨大的争论？对。好吧。
What do we think here in the studio? Do you think it's a Christmas movie? Do you vote yes or no? I'm just saying no. Whenever I think of this movie, I don't think of it as Christmas, you know? Even though that is the backdrop for it. Okay. Cassie, Jordan, Eduardo.
我们在演播室里的大家觉得呢？你觉得它是一部圣诞电影吗？你投赞成票还是反对票？我只想说不是。每当我想到这部电影时，我不会把它和圣诞节联系在一起，你知道的？尽管那是故事的背景。好吧。卡西（Cassie）、乔丹（Jordan）、爱德华多（Eduardo）。
This is Jordan. I do not think it's a Christmas movie. Okay. It is absolutely a Christmas movie. Oh my God! Eduardo coming in hot! Cassie? Just because it's around Christmas doesn't make it a Christmas movie. Thank you, Cassie. Thank you, Cassie.
我是乔丹。我不觉得这是一部圣诞电影。好吧。它绝对是一部圣诞电影。哦天哪！爱德华多带着火气上场了！卡西？仅仅因为它发生在圣诞节前后并不能让它成为一部圣诞电影。谢谢你，卡西。谢谢你，卡西。
I feel seen. Eduardo, let me just say, at Christmas, I get inspired to watch Die Hard. So I'm gonna put it as yes, a Christmas movie. All right, it's three to two. In December, 2023, Yahoo News, YouGov did a poll, and 50% of the people polled said no. Mm.
我感觉被理解了。爱德华多，请允许我说，到了圣诞节，我就会受到启发去看《虎胆龙威》。所以我投赞成票，这是一部圣诞电影。好吧，现在是三比二。在2023年12月，雅虎新闻和YouGov做过一次民意调查，50%的受访者投了反对票。嗯。
26 said yes. Okay. 23 said they aren't sure. Okay. And only 14% of people said that they watch it over the holidays. Well, Yahoo UK had an article, and they have some criteria for whether or not something is a Christmas movie and they said you can figure out if something is a Christmas movie by asking these two questions.
26%的人投了赞成票。好吧。23%的人表示不确定。好吧。只有14%的人说他们会在节假日期间观看这部电影。好吧，雅虎英国（Yahoo UK）曾发表过一篇文章，里面提到了一些判断一部作品是否为圣诞电影的标准，他们说你可以通过问这两个问题来弄清楚某部作品是不是圣诞电影。
I'm so curious. Number one, does watching the film at any other time of year feel weird? If the answer is no, then it is not a Christmas movie. I mean, the answer is no for me. I could watch Die Hard anytime. Right, but for example, you probably wouldn't watch Christmas Vacation. Yes. Right.
我太好奇了。第一，在一年中的其他任何时间看这部电影会不会觉得奇怪？如果答案是否定的，那它就不是圣诞电影。我的意思是，对我和说答案是否定的。我随时都可以看《虎胆龙威》。没错，但举个例子，你可能不会去看《疯狂圣诞假期》。是的。没错。
But what about the movie Home Alone? Is that a Christmas movie? I mean, I think so. But it's also just a comedy. Home Alone, is that a Christmas movie? I mean, I think so. But it's also just a comedy. Couldn't you watch that in the summer? And it's about a kid who's home alone? You think...
那《小鬼当家》呢？那是圣诞电影吗？我的意思是，我觉得是。但它同时也是一部喜剧。《小鬼当家》，那是圣诞电影吗？我的意思是，我觉得是。但它同时也是一部喜剧。难道你不能在夏天看吗？而且讲的是一个小孩独自在家？你觉得……
I don't know. It's winter. There's snow everywhere. Planes, trains, and automobiles. I could watch that anytime. Okay. All right. Here's the second question.
我不知道。外面是冬天。到处都是雪。《飞机、火车和汽车》。我什么时候都能看。好吧。好吧。这是第二个问题。
If you take Christmas out of the movie, does it still make sense? If the answer is yes, it's not a Christmas movie. That's a good one. That's a good question. I think you could take Christmas out of Die Hard, and it's still Die Hard. Yes. So there's a lot of evidence here now
如果把圣诞节从电影中拿掉，它还讲得通吗？如果答案是肯定的，那它就不是圣诞电影。这问得好。是个好问题。我觉得你可以把圣诞节从《虎胆龙威》里拿掉，它依然是《虎胆龙威》。是的。所以现在有很多证据表明
that Die Hard is not a Christmas movie. I will tell you that Die Hard director John McTiernan spoke at the American Film Institute in 2020. And here's what he had to say. He said, we hadn't intended it to be a Christmas movie, but the joy that came from it is what turned it into a Christmas movie. So John McTiernan says, yes, it's a Christmas movie. I don't know if he said
《虎胆龙威》不是一部圣诞电影。我得告诉你们，《虎胆龙威》的导演约翰·麦克蒂尔南（John McTiernan）在2020年的美国电影学会（American Film Institute）上发表过讲话。他是这么说的。他说，我们本来没打算把它拍成圣诞电影，但其中散发出的欢乐才是把它变成圣诞电影的原因。所以约翰·麦克蒂尔南说，是的，这是一部圣诞电影。我不知道他有没有说
yes I think he just likes that people have attached this sort of debate to it and the fun of it. Well I think the ultimate authority on whether or not this is a Christmas movie is Bruce Willis right? Yes. All right well Bruce Willis he had his roast on Comedy Central. He was roasted in 2018. What did he say? He addressed it at his roast. Here's an audio clip.
是的，我觉得他只是喜欢人们把这种争论附加在它上面，以及这带来的乐趣。好吧，我认为关于这到底是不是圣诞电影的终极权威是布鲁斯·威利斯（Bruce Willis），对吧？是的。好吧，布鲁斯·威利斯，他在喜剧中心（Comedy Central）举办过他的吐槽大会。他在2018年被吐槽了。他说什么了？他在吐槽大会上谈到了这件事。这里有一段音频。
People ask me why I did this first. Was it because one of the last guys who did it became president? Hell no. Why would I want to be president when I can just keep being Bruce f***ing Willis? Yeah. I did this roast for one reason
人们问我为什么先做这个。是因为上一个这么做的人后来当了总统吗？见鬼才不是。当我能继续做布鲁斯·他妈的·威利斯的时候，我为什么还要当总统？是的。我做这个吐槽大会只有一个原因，
and for one reason only, to settle something once and for all. Now please listen very carefully. Die Hard is not a Christmas movie. It's a Bruce Willis movie. How about that? There you have it. All right.
而且只有一个原因，那就是一劳永逸地解决这个争端。现在请仔细听好。《虎胆龙威》不是一部圣诞电影。这是一部布鲁斯·威利斯电影。觉得怎么样？这就是真相。好吧。
Well, in the kitchen, Jim is gonna share with Stanley, Toby and Creed about his new There you have it. All right. Well, in the kitchen, Jim is going to share with Stanley, Toby, and Creed about his new job in Philly. Darryl enters. He's really happy for Jim, but he's like, hey, are you ready to go? Do you have everything? Are you missing something? Yeah. Then Darryl has a talking head where he says, Jim promised to take me to Philly. That was two months ago, and he hasn't heard anything since. He said that, right? And we go back to the kitchen and Jim is like, I don't think so. Not forgetting anything. This is going to send Daryl on a journey.
嗯，在厨房里，吉姆（Jim）要和斯坦利（Stanley）、托比（Toby）以及克里德（Creed）分享他在费城的新工作。达里尔（Daryl）进来了。他真的为吉姆感到高兴，但他就像是，嘿，你准备好出发了吗？你都收拾好了吗？你有什么落下的吗？是的。然后达里尔有一个单人采访镜头，他说吉姆答应带他去费城。那是两个月前的事了，从那以后他就再没听到任何消息。他是这么说的，对吧？然后镜头回到厨房，吉姆就说，我觉得没有。没有落下任何东西。这让达里尔踏上了一段旅程。
A true spiral. A true spiral. If there ever was one. Toby, of course, relates everything back to his time as a juror on the Scranton Strangler trial. This was like a huge moment for Toby. Yeah, it's like his one claim to fame. It is, it is. He points out that the man alleged to be the Scranton Strangler is someone who won't
彻彻底底的抓狂。彻彻底底的抓狂。如果真要说有什么的话。托比当然把一切都联系到了他当斯克兰顿绞杀魔案陪审员的经历上。这对托比来说简直是个高光时刻。对，这就像是他仅有的成名事迹。确实，确实。他指出，那个被指控为斯克兰顿绞杀魔的人是个不会
be working on anything new or exciting. He's in prison for something he may not have done. Oh no. Nellie's like, what? What are you talking about? The Scranton who? Oh no. Oh boy. Yep., what? What are you talking about? The Scranton who? Oh, no. Oh, boy.
去从事任何新鲜或刺激工作的人。他因为可能根本不是他干的事而在坐牢。哦，不。内莉（Nellie）一脸：什么？你在说什么？哪个斯克兰顿？哦，不。哦，天哪。是的，什么？你在说什么？哪个斯克兰顿？哦，不。哦，天哪。
Yep. Toby lights up. He's so excited. He has someone new to share this whole story with. How much did you love John and Craig's exit from the kitchen? So great. I love Stanley's exit, too.
是的。托比双眼放光。他太兴奋了。他有了一个可以分享这个完整故事的新听众。你们有多喜欢约翰和克雷格离开厨房的那一幕？太棒了。我也喜欢斯坦利的退场。
He's like, all right. See you. Good luck with that. Yeah, see you in a few hours. Yep. I want to point out the background of this scene. This is a very good example of how during our entire nine years on this show, we were always doing background
他就像是，好吧。回见。祝你好运。对，过几个小时见。是的。我想指出这个场景的背景。这是一个非常好的例子，说明在我们在这部剧里的整整九年里，我们总是在为其他演员的场景做背景
work for other actors' scenes. Did you notice Aaron and Pete are in the background and Pete is actively reciting Die Hard to Aaron all throughout this entire scene. They're just in the background. You can't hear them. You can barely see them, but you can see him moving. Great background acting commitment. I mean, probably three hours they spent in the background while we did this kitchen scene. Right. Yep. Back at Angela's party planning committee meeting, Pam is really trying to make a case for Dwight's Christmas.
工作。你们注意到了吗，艾伦（Aaron）和皮特在背景里，而且皮特在这个场景的整个过程中都在积极地向艾伦背诵《虎胆龙威》。他们就在背景里。你听不到他们的声音。你几乎看不到他们，但你能看到他在动。伟大的背景表演投入。我的意思是，我们在拍这个厨房场景时，他们大概在背景里待了三个小时。没错。是的。回到安吉拉（Angela）的派对策划委员会会议上，帕姆（Pam）真的在极力为德怀特的圣诞节争取支持。
Yeah. And guess what? She gets everyone on board, everyone but Angela. Angela does not want her name on this. I love this so much. She was like, please do not attach my name to this. And Pam's like, where? Where's your name going to appear? And Oscar's like, just take her name off of it. I know. I love Oscar in that moment. So the PPC emerged from the conference room to announce we are doing Dwight's Christmas, but there is a rule. The one rule is there are no rules. Dwight's like, you have never been cooler. I mean, Pam has made his day. Jim applauds, he's so happy.
对。你猜怎么着？她把所有人都拉进来了，除了安吉拉。安吉拉可不想让自己的名字出现在这上面。我太喜欢这个了。她当时说，请千万别把我的名字和这扯上关系。然后帕姆说，哪儿？你的名字会出现在哪儿？奥斯卡（Oscar）就说，直接把她的名字去掉吧。我懂。我太喜欢那一刻的奥斯卡了。于是派对策划委员会从会议室出来宣布我们要办德怀特的圣诞节，但有一个规则。唯一的规则就是没有规则。德怀特觉得：你们从来没这么酷过。我的意思是，帕姆让他度过了美好的一天。吉姆鼓掌，他太高兴了。
Best Christmas ever. So we reached out to Rainn Wilson about this episode and he sent in some audio clips. And the first one he shares with us about working with Charles McDougall and also how this idea had been around for a long time. Hello office ladies, and who's your old friend, Rainn Wilson. And what an honor and pleasure it was
史上最棒的圣诞节。所以我们联系了雷恩·威尔逊（Rainn Wilson）来聊聊这一集，他发来了一些音频剪辑。他跟我们分享的第一件事是关于和查尔斯·麦克杜格尔（Charles McDougall）合作的感受，以及这个创意是如何由来已久的。哈啰，办公室女士们，还有你们的老朋友雷恩·威尔逊。能
to go back and watch The White Christmas. I don't think I had seen it since it first came out, 10 years ago, 11 years ago, something like that. It was so much fun to watch. It brought so many memories back. Had such a great time shooting it. The director of that episode was the famous Charles McDougal, who would always do 47 takes with camera angles.
回头重看《德怀特的圣诞节》真是我的荣幸和乐趣。我想自从它10年前、11年前刚首播以来，我就再没看过它了。看它真的太有趣了。勾起了好多回忆。拍摄的时候度过了非常棒的时光。那一集的导演是著名的查尔斯·麦克杜格尔，他总是会用不同的机位拍47条。
For those of you keeping track, like watch how many different places the cameras are in and that there is no possible way in heaven that this is a mockumentary with two cameras wandering around an office capturing things. But we had a long let go of that conceit by season nine. I know that Justin Spitzer had been wanting to do this belchnickle thing for a long time. They'd been trying to figure out an episode for it. I think he had come up with the idea and the research
对于那些在关注的人，比如看看摄像机在多少不同的地方出现，这绝对不可能是一部伪纪录片，里面有两个摄像机在办公室里走来走去捕捉画面。但到了第九季，我们早就放弃这种伪纪录片的设定了。我知道贾斯汀·斯普策（Justin Spitzer）很早就想搞这个贝尔施尼克（Belchnickle）的东西了。他们一直在试图为它构思一集。我想他当时想出了这个创意和研究，
and was very excited about it. Yeah, you know what? I remember that. I think this episode of Dwight hosting the Christmas was supposed to happen during the year of the strike. I do sort of vaguely remember, like, it was a card on the wall, right? Yes, yes. And they were working towards it. Yeah, but then we did not end up having a Christmas episode that year. And so I think it had been on the shelf ever since then. Well, I guess Dwight just keeps a horn laying around because he's going to blow this horn.
而且对此非常兴奋。对，你知道吗？我记得那个。我觉得德怀特主持圣诞节这一集本该在罢工的那一年播出。我确实有点模糊地记得，就像墙上的一张卡片对吧？是的，是的。他们一直朝着这个方向努力。对，但那年我们最后没有拍成圣诞集。所以我想它从那以后就一直被搁置了。好吧，我猜德怀特只是随手放了一个号角，因为他要吹响这个号角了。
Pennsylvania Dutch Christmas has officially begun. He immediately already has a spread of food and wine. I don't know how he threw this together. He was ready to go. Meredith is going to take a sip of the Glow Wine. And she, people are like, really not really loving the Glow Wine. It's very thick, she says. Is this lava? I want you to know, I looked up Glow Wine recipes. You didn't make it, did you? Josh made it. Is it here? Yes.
宾夕法尼亚荷兰人的圣诞节正式开始了。他立刻就摆好了一桌子的食物和热红酒（Glühwein）。我不知道他是怎么把这些凑齐的。他随时准备开干。梅雷迪思（Meredith）要喝上一口热红酒。她，大家好像，真的不是特别喜欢这热红酒。她说，这太浓了。这是岩浆吗？我想让你们知道，我查了热红酒的食谱。你没自己做吧？乔许（Josh）做的。在这儿吗？是的。
Dear God. But wait, listen. Oh my God. Oh my god. I'm scared. No, do not be scared. I haven't tried it yet. No, I wanted to try it the same time you tried it. Oh my god. Here, I want you to know I found this recipe on all recipes.com. Okay. Glow wine is a hot spiced quote Glow wine found in many winter markets in Germany and Austria And you know what you come in from the cold and snow and this Warm spice mold drink is supposed to make you glow with warmth Inside this recipe is from elsie. Elsie says my father would make this for new year's eve Listen to the ingredients before you get scared, okay?
天啊。但等等，听着。哦，天哪。哦，天哪。我好害怕。不，不要害怕。我还没尝过呢。不，我想和你同时尝。哦，天哪。来吧，我想让你们知道我是从allrecipes.com上找到这个食谱的。好吧。热红酒是一种热的香料，呃，很多德国和奥地利的冬季集市上都能找到热红酒，
Okay, okay, okay. I'm just saying the visual in the episode is not appealing. I know, that's why. But now I'm hearing that it's meant to be, it's like a mulled wine, it's like served warm. I felt like I had to find out, is Glow Wine a real thing, is it gross, is it not, and it sounds lovely, and it is a real thing.
你知道吗，当你从寒冷和冰雪中走进来时，这种温热的香料热饮应该能让你由内而外地散发出温暖。这个食谱来自埃尔茜（Elsie）。埃尔茜说我父亲会在除夕夜做这个。在你们害怕之前先听听配料，好吗？
The ingredients are water, sugar, cinnamon stick, oranges, cloves, and a bottle of red wine. And you cook it up. Well, that sounds delicious. I know, you cook it up and serve it hot. And I was gonna make it last night, but I was making Sam's scrapbook. Yes.
好吧，好吧，好吧。我只是觉得这一集里的视觉效果不太吸引人。我知道，这就是为什么。但现在我听说它是本该如此的，就像是热红酒，是热着端上来的。我觉得我必须弄清楚，热红酒是真实存在的东西吗？它很难喝吗？还是不难喝？听起来很不错，而且它确实是真实存在的。
And Josh was like, babe, I'll make it for you. So he made it and I have it here and we're gonna try some glue wine. All right. So you get a little orange garnish and you these oranges were from my tree. Wow, this, I mean now I'm excited. I know. It's not as thick as what we had on set or is it? We don't know yet. I don't know. I doubt it. And it's also not being served with the spoon that guided your head through the birth canal. Exactly. So it's supposed to be served warm because you know, oh, it's steaming. These are cold. You know, you're in a lot of I guess tourists like to get it after they ski. Oh, well now you're speaking my language, Angela. I know.
配料是水、糖、肉桂棒、橙子、丁香和一瓶红酒。然后你把它煮开。嗯，听起来很好吃。我知道，你把它煮开然后热着端上来。我本来昨晚要做的，但我在做萨姆（Sam）的剪贴簿。是的。
Okay, here you go. Thank you. Thank you. Enjoy your Glühwein. It smells good and I'm imagining that I'm chilly. I'm cold. Oh, I even have snow on my hair. Oh my gosh.
然后乔许就说，宝贝，我来给你做。所以他做了，我这儿有，我们要尝尝热红酒。好吧。所以你会得到一点橙子装饰，这些橙子是我树上结的。哇，这个，我现在有点激动了。我知道。它不像我们在片场喝的那样浓，对吧？我们还不知道。我不知道。我怀疑不是。而且它也没有配上一把曾引导你的头通过产道的勺子。没错。所以它应该热着喝，因为你知道，哦，在冒热气。这些是凉的。你知道，你在很多，我猜游客滑雪完后都喜欢喝这个。哦，好吧，现在你说到我心坎里去了，安吉拉。我知道。
Ooh. Oh, it's fantastic. That is wonderful. It's real good. It's real good. That is wonderful. It's real good. It's real good. Josh did great. I know. He's good.
好啦，给你。谢谢。谢谢。请享用你的热红酒。闻起来很香，我幻想着自己正在瑟瑟发抖。我很冷。哦，我头发上甚至还有雪。哦，天哪。
It literally means to light you from within, like to warm you up. Lit from within. Well, Angela, I'm really glad you did that. And thank you, Josh. I know. It's delicious. It is really good, isn't it? We also, we got a fan mail flurry asking what parts of Dwight's Christmas are based in fact.
噢。哦，太棒了。这太美妙了。真的很好喝。真的很好喝。这太美妙了。真的很好喝。真的很好喝。乔许做得真棒。我知道。他很厉害。
Oh I bet because there's a lot of random stuff he's sharing. Yes and writer Robert Padnick said that there wasn't actually a lot of information about a Pennsylvania Dutch Christmas or Belschnickle, who we'll be meeting in a minute, that was kind of out on the internet at the time. But they were very careful to not make anything up. He said that our writers, Jonathan Green and Gabe Miller, did a lot of work on this episode and included a number of real traditions. We also got a fan letter from Andreas H. in Germany who said, Hi office ladies. This episode calls for a deep dive into German Christmas traditions.
它字面上的意思是让你从内部亮起来，也就是让你暖和起来。由内而外地发光。好吧，安吉拉，我真的很高兴你做了这个。谢谢你，乔许。我知道。很好喝。真的很好喝，对吧？我们还，我们收到了大量粉丝来信，问德怀特的圣诞节有哪些部分是基于真实事实的。
And since I am from Germany and I love Christmas, I took the liberty of assisting you in your research. Oh my gosh, awesome. Andreas said though, beware, this will take some time and some weird turns. Oh! Andreas said, let's break down the props and decorations first. Andreas, I'm loving everything about this as I sip my glue wine and listen. I know, isn't this perfect?
哦，我敢打赌，因为他分享了很多随机的东西。是的，编剧罗伯特·帕德尼克说，其实网上当时并没有太多关于宾夕法尼亚荷兰人圣诞节或贝尔施尼克的资料——我们一会儿就会见到他。但他们非常小心，没有胡编乱造。他说我们的编剧乔纳森·格林（Jonathan Green）和盖布·米勒（Gabe Miller）在这集上做了大量工作，融入了许多真正的传统。我们还收到了一封来自德国安德烈亚斯·H（Andreas H.）的粉丝信，他说：哈啰，办公室女士们。这一集需要深入探讨德国的圣诞传统。
Yeah. So the first thing that Andreas pointed out was the starry light thing above reception, which Angela, you know, we called the Death Star. We did call it the Death Star. This is not a reference to Star Wars. It's just the fact that it was really pointy and sharp and several people walked into it and got injured. They did.
既然我来自德国又热爱圣诞节，我就自作主张来协助你们做研究了。哦，天哪，太棒了。不过安德烈亚斯说，小心，这会花点时间，而且会有一些奇怪的转折。哦！安德烈亚斯说，我们先来剖析一下道具和装饰。安德烈亚斯，我一边啜饮着热红酒一边听，我对这一切简直爱不释手。我知道，这不是很完美吗？
And then, like midway through the first day, there had been so many injuries. It was hung so low by reception that they put corks on the end of all the points and they draped it in like caution tape. So many people walked into this thing. Someone cut their forehead. Remember? Yeah, I can't remember who that was, but more than one person. More than one person. And who knew we were going gonna have to have a safety meeting about this prop? Yes. We probably should have.
对。所以安德烈亚斯指出的第一件事就是前台上方那个星形灯饰，安吉拉，你知道的，我们管它叫死星（Death Star）。我们确实叫它死星。这跟《星球大战》无关。纯粹是因为它真的很尖锐，好几个人撞上去还受了伤。确实撞了。
We took pictures of it, and it's one of the things that I wish we had the room to write about in our book. I know, we debated this. Remember when we were writing our book, we were like, we want a page dedicated to the Death Star. Because this is one of the things that has gone down in like the cast lore.
然后，大概在第一天快过半的时候，已经有太多人受伤了。它在前台挂得太低了，以至于他们在所有尖角上都套上了软木塞，还缠上了类似警戒线的东西。好多人都撞到了这玩意儿。有人额头都划破了。还记得吗？对，我不记得那是谁了，但绝对不止一个人。不止一个人。谁知道我们还得为这个道具开个安全会议呢？是的。我们可能真该开个。
Yes. Was navigating this very dangerous prop in the middle of our main walkway of the show. Well, this item is called the Hörnhütherstern. It can also be called the Moravee. Oh boy. It can be, I'm just gonna move on. I'm not laughing at the name.
我们给它拍了照，这是我希望我们的书里有足够篇幅去写的事情之一。我知道，我们讨论过这个。还记得我们在写书的时候，我们就在想，我们想要有一页专门留给死星。因为这是作为演员的内部传说流传下来的事情之一。
I'm laughing at Jenna's attempt to say it. I know, I'm gonna just, let's try it. Okay. You could call it the Moravian star. Okay. This star is very popular and a very common Christmas decoration, especially in the regions of the former GDR, but in general all over Germany. It is usually not black, however, but red, white or yellow, which you would be able to see better and not walk into.
是的。那就是在我们节目的主要过道中间避开这个极其危险的道具。好吧，这个东西叫做莫拉维亚星（Hörnhütherstern）。它也可以叫做莫拉维亚星（Moravee）。哦，天哪。它可以，我还是直接跳过去吧。我不是在笑这个名字。
Yes, definitely yellow. Andreas did also mention Glow Wine and said it is something that you cannot escape in Germany around Christmas time. You'll find it at every Christmas fair, every university, every workplace Christmas party. I can see why. It's delicious and warm and cozy. Well, Andreas said there's even a non-alcoholic children's version called Kinderpunsch. Oh, come on. And it's basically a fruit infusion with apple, orange juice, and then the spices of cinnamon
我是在笑詹娜试图念出它。我知道，我准备，我们再试一次。好吧。你可以叫它莫拉维亚星（Moravian star）。好吧。这颗星非常受欢迎，是一种非常常见的圣诞装饰，特别是在前东德地区，但总的来说在整个德国都很流行。不过它通常不是黑色的，而是红色的、白色的或黄色的，这样你就能看清它而不会撞上去了。
and cloves warmed up. I really wish Dwight had had some Kinderpunsch. I know. It's... I love it. Andreas also said, I don't recognize any of the food, but Dwight mentions hasenfeffer. This is a rabbit ragu. He said it traditionally consists
对，绝对是黄色的。安德烈亚斯还提到了热红酒，并说这是你在圣诞节期间在德国绝对无法避开的东西。你在每个圣诞集市、每个大学、每个职场圣诞派对上都能找到它。我能理解为什么。它又美味又温暖又舒适。好吧，安德烈亚斯说甚至还有一种不含酒精的儿童版，叫做儿童潘趣酒（Kinderpunsch）。哦，拜托。它基本上就是一种水果浸泡饮品，里面有苹果、橙汁，然后加上肉桂和丁香的香料。
of all of the leftovers of the rabbit, like the heart, liver, limbs, and neck. And then it is braised in rabbit's blood. So if you're in Germany and you order the hasenfeffer, is this the hasas and Pfeffer from Le Fond et Chirly? We're gonna do it. Haas and Pfeffer incorporated.
加热过的。我真的很希望德怀特当时能有一些儿童潘趣酒。我知道。这……我太喜欢了。安德烈亚斯还说，我不认识那些食物，但德怀特提到了野兔肉酱（hasenfeffer）。这是一种兔肉杂烩。他说它传统上包含
Can't be. Is it? Can't be. I mean, that's what I thought of the minute I heard Haas and Pfeffer, but it is also a dish made up of rabbit leftovers. I don't think that's what they're thinking about at the beginning of their TV show. Is it also a name? Could you be named Hassan Pfeffer? Yes. I'm going to say yes.
兔子身上所有的边角料，比如心脏、肝脏、四肢和脖子。然后用兔血来焖煮。所以如果你在德国点野兔肉酱，这就是《当哈利遇到莎妮》里的哈斯和佩费尔（Haas and Pfeffer）吗？我们要做了。哈斯和佩费尔公司。
Yes. So then your name means rabbit leftovers stew. Stew. Okay. Well. There you go. There you go. I mean, my last name means Fisher. It's very literal. Like someone going fishing? I mean, I think so. Although it is the German spelling, it's F-I-S-C-H-E-R. I don't know what my last name means.
不可能吧。是吗？不可能吧。我的意思是，我一听到哈斯和佩费尔就想到了这个，但它确实也是一道由兔肉边角料做成的菜。我不觉得他们在电视剧一开始想的是这个。这也是一个名字吗？你可以叫哈桑·佩费尔吗？可以。我猜可以。
Kinsey? Mm-hmm. Someone could probably tell us. You know what? We didn't look it up. We didn't look it up. And it's going to remain a mystery today. I know, for today.
可以。所以你的名字意思就是兔子边角料炖菜。炖菜。好吧。那就这样吧。那就这样吧。我的意思是，我的姓氏意思是渔夫。非常直译。就像去捕鱼的人？我的意思是，我觉得是。虽然它是德语拼写，F-I-S-C-H-E-R。我不知道我的姓氏是什么意思。
Pam and Jim have a talking head. Is this what they thought it would be? Guys, it's even better. It's even better. Dwight is holding a candle. He's reading a poem. Jim is super happy. Andreas from Germany said the poem that Dwight is reciting
金西（Kinsey）？嗯哼。可能有人能告诉我们。你知道吗？我们没查过。我们没查过。这在今天将永远是个谜。我知道，就今天而言。
is a poem called Advent by a famous romantic German poet, Ranje Maria Rilke, real poem. Oh, well Dwight's poem is interrupted by the sound of something on the roof. Dwight excuses himself to run to his car. He says, I gotta take a dump. What? He's like a 13 year old boy.
帕姆和吉姆有一个单人采访。这是他们想象中的样子吗？伙计们，这甚至更好。甚至更好。德怀特拿着一支蜡烛。他正在读一首诗。吉姆超级开心。来自德国的安德烈亚斯说，德怀特正在背诵的那首诗
This is his excuse to get out. I've gotta take a dump. Kevin says, I wish my car had a bathroom, which I thought was so funny. Well, you were speaking. I took another sip of my Glow wine and it is just so good. I know. I'm gonna put Elsie's recipe in our stories
是一首名为《降临节》（Advent）的诗，由著名的浪漫主义德国诗人赖纳·玛利亚·里尔克（Rainer Maria Rilke）所写，是一首真正的诗。哦，好吧，德怀特的诗被屋顶上某种声音打断了。德怀特告辞去跑向他的车。他说，我要去拉个屎。什么？他就像个13岁的男孩。
because it's delicious. Well, everybody, you should make it because it's good. Or you could make the Kinder Punch version. Yeah. Well, now we're gonna to go back to the annex. And Pete is still reciting Die Hard. And Erin is following along using a script that she found on the internet.
这是他开溜的借口。我要去拉个屎。凯文说，我希望我的车里也有个洗手间，我觉得这太搞笑了。好吧，就在你说话的时候。我又喝了一口我的热红酒，真的是太好喝了。我知道。我会把埃尔茜的食谱发到我们的快拍里，
And she thinks Pete gets something wrong. And he says, no, no, no, no, no. Your script is wrong. That's right. That's how well he knows it. Well, this scene was much longer. And it's in deleted scenes. I have to play it because Jake Lacey is crushing it.
因为真的很好喝。好吧，各位，你们都应该做一个尝尝，因为确实很好喝。或者你也可以做儿童潘趣酒的版本。对。好吧，现在我们要回到侧边办公室了。皮特还在背《虎胆龙威》。而艾伦正拿着她在网上找到的剧本跟着对照。
Jake, someday when you're on our podcast, this is just one of the things we want to talk to you about. Oh my gosh, is he great in this scene? You got to hear it. The fire has been called off, my friend. No one is coming to help you. You might as well come out and join the others. I promise I won't hurt you.
并且她觉得皮特有地方背错了。而他说，不，不，不，不，不。你的剧本错了。就是这样。他就是这么熟悉它。好吧，这个场景本来要长得多。而且它被剪进了删除片段里。我必须把它放出来，因为杰克·莱西（Jake Lacy）演得太棒了。
Do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do John McLean's not there again? No. How is that possible? The sound he heard before, nothing but a band song running in the wind. All of a sudden, drop it dickhead, it's the police. Y'all not going to, it's me. Oh yeah, why not? Okay, wait, I have to pee. I'll be right back. Yeah, sure. Hey, do you mind if maybe I just keep going?
杰克，哪天你来我们的播客时，这绝对是我们想跟你聊的事情之一。哦，天哪，他在这个场景里是不是绝了？你们得听听这个。火已经被取消了，我的朋友。没有人会来救你的。你还不如出来和大家一起。我保证不会伤害你的。
You mean like by yourself? Yeah, just kind kinda in the flow. Yeah, sure. Okay. Because you are policemen, there are rules for policemen. That's what my captain keeps telling me. Elbow to the face.
约翰·麦克莱恩又不在那儿？不。这怎么可能？他刚才听到的声音，不过是风中吹拂的一首乐队的歌。突然间，放下它，混蛋，我是警察。你们不会，是我。哦，是吗，为什么不？等等，我想尿尿。我马上回来。好吧，当然。嘿，你介不介意我继续？
Oh! My pistol, my pistol. Jake! I know! Oh, my gosh. He knows the whole movie. It is amazing. I can't imagine how much time he spent. And it's so physical, too. He has a fight with two people, but he's just himself playing both people. I can't even imagine what that looks like because it sounded incredible. I know.
你是说你自己一个人？对，就，就顺着这个状态。好吧，当然。好吧。因为你们是警察，警察是有规矩的。我的队长一直这么告诉我。手肘击面。
I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know.
哦！我的手枪，我的手枪。杰克！我知道！哦，天哪。他整部电影都能背下来。太惊人了。我无法想象他花了多少时间。而且肢体动作也超多。他和两个人打架，但他只是一个人分饰两角。我甚至无法想象那看起来是什么样，因为听起来太不可思议了。我知道。
I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I know. I himself playing both people. I can't even imagine what that looks like because it sounded incredible. I know it's so good it's in deleted scenes. While we're talking Die Hard for a minute here there's one part about that movie that is so stressful to me every time I watch it. It's so incredibly
我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。
stressful. I have a couple of stressful moments as well. I wonder if it's the same. For me, it's that he is barefoot. Yes, yes. The whole movie, it makes me so unsettled. I was gonna say that, and then he gets the glass in his foot. Yes. And then you know he has to walk on it,
我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。我知道。他自己扮演两个人。我甚至无法想象那看起来是什么样，因为听起来太不可思议了。我知道演得太好了以至于被剪进了删除片段。既然我们在这儿聊了一会儿《虎胆龙威》，这部电影里有一个部分每次我看的时候都让我感到压力山大。真的太令人
and you know what that does to me. It's a wound on a wound. He's a, yes. Yes. Shoot the glass. The glass. What? What? Shoot the glass.
窒息了。我也有几个感到压力的时刻。不知道是不是同一个。对我来说，就是他光着脚。是的，是的。整部电影，都让我觉得好不安。我刚想说这个，然后他的脚踩到了玻璃上。是的。然后你知道他必须踩着它走，
Yes. He has to run through the glass. Run through the glass barefoot. And then he has to fish it out. Yeah. A big hunk of glass. I can't, I can't. Oh my goodness.
而且你知道那对我来说意味着什么。那是伤口上撒盐。他，是的。是的。射击玻璃。玻璃。什么？什么？射击玻璃。
Yep. Well, Erin is now gonna get an email from Andy. He's reached land, he sold the boat, got super drunk, then watched Life of Pi, got really introspective, and now he's going to hang out there for a couple of weeks and try to figure this whole life thing out, maybe see the Hobbit. There were some candy bag alts for this. For this email? Oh-hmm. Oh please do tell. Okay there were several. I'm gonna just share two with you because I think our writers really love doing candy bag alts for things like this because sometimes there's pages. Here's one. What up shorty? Just sold the boat, got super
是的。他必须跑过玻璃。光着脚跑过玻璃。然后他得把它挑出来。对。很大一块玻璃。我不能，我不能。哦天哪。
depressed, gonna hang down here for a while and search the old soul. Maybe try some surfing. Back soon. Love you loads. Sad and scared. Andy." Search the old soul. I love that. I love how you said it like Andy. Here's the next one. Girlfriend, it's boyfriend. How are you? I'm fine. Actually sort of train wrecking right now. Got some stuff to figure back in a month. I miss you, I love you so much. I realized I forgot to leave food for my bird.
是的。好吧，艾伦现在要收到安迪发的一封邮件了。他已经登陆了，把船卖了，喝得酩酊大名，然后看了《少年派的奇幻漂流》，开始变得非常有内省精神，现在他打算在那里晃荡几个星期，试图弄清楚生活的意义，也许还能看看《霍比特人》。这个电子邮件有一些糖果包替代版。为了这封邮件？哦——嗯。哦，快讲讲。好吧，有好几个。我只跟你们分享两个，因为我觉得我们的编剧非常喜欢为这种事情做糖果包替代版，因为有时候会有好几页。这是其中一个。最近怎么样，小个子？刚把船卖了，超级
So if you could check in and feed them or bury them, that'd be swell. Oh no. And he has a bird? Who hasn't been fed in several weeks now. Yeah, Erin comes back from reading this email and she is hurt. And she's bummed out and she is, she is hurt. Yeah.
沮丧，打算在这儿晃荡一段时间，寻找一下古老的灵魂。也许去冲浪试试。马上回去。深爱着你。伤心又害怕。安迪。寻找古老的灵魂。我太喜欢这个了。我太喜欢你学安迪说话的语气了。这是下一个。女朋友，我是男朋友。你好吗？我很好。其实现在正处于一团糟的状态。有些事情需要弄清楚，一个月后回去。我想你，我太爱你了。我发现我忘了给我的鸟留食物了。
And she's bummed out and she says, why don't we watch this movie? Why are we talking about it? And he's like, oh. And the way he said oh, it's as if she said, why don't we make out? I don't know. Like it landed so meaningful to him. Like oh, oh, we're gonna, we're gonna hang, we're gonna actually hang out and like sit next to each other and watch a movie. Well, lucky lucky for him he has a copy or two in his car. That's how much
所以如果你能去看看并喂喂它们，或者把它们埋了，那就太好了。哦，不。他还有只鸟？已经有好几个星期没喂食了。对，艾伦读完这封邮件回来了，她受伤了。她很沮丧，而且她，她受伤了。对。
this guy loves Die Hard. Dwight had a horn in his car. Pete has Die Hard in his car. I'd like to point out that during this whole scene of Pete and Erin if you look through the doorway window you can see Toby and Nellie in there talking about the Scranton Strangler. Yes. Once again, we're just doing the background work for our fellow actors. That's right.
而且她很沮丧，并且她说，我们为什么不看这部电影？我们为什么要聊这个？而他说，哦。他发出“哦”的那种语气，就好像她说的是，我们为什么不亲热一番？我不知道。就好像这句话对他来说意义重大。就像“哦，哦，我们要去，我们要去闲逛，我们要真正地闲逛，然后坐在一起看电影”。好吧，他真走运，他的车里有一两份拷贝。这就是为什么
Very big part of being on The Office. Well, Kevin now is really enjoying the hog mama, but he spits it out when Phyllis tells him it's hog maw. I like to call bullsh** on Kevin spitting out anything. He eats brown, remember? Like the title hogma is gonna throw him. Well, also at this point he's tasted it. And liked it.
这家伙这么爱《虎胆龙威》。德怀特的车里有个号角。皮特的车里有《虎胆龙威》。我想指出的是，在皮特和艾伦的整个场景中，如果你透过门上的窗户看，你能看到托比和内莉在那里面谈论斯克兰顿绞杀魔。是的。再一次，我们只是在为我们的同行演员做背景工作。没错。
Right. I accept that bullsh** card. Thank you. That's well played. Thank you. We had a fan question from Eve H in Portland Portland, Oregon, who said, My grandmother has cooked hogmaw for many holidays. Oh. She doesn't anymore because she says it's too much work.
这是参演《办公室》非常重要的一部分。好吧，现在凯文真的很喜欢猪胃香肠（hog maw），但当菲利斯告诉他那是猪胃时，他把它吐了出来。我觉得凯文吐出任何东西都是在扯淡。他连棕色的东西都吃，记得吗？就像猪胃这个名字会把他吓到一样。好吧，而且此时此刻他已经尝过了。并且很喜欢。
But Eve says, I can say it is delicious. What is it? It is a pig stomach. Okay. That is stuffed. Eve says, I know the idea of a pig's stomach sounds gross, but it's actually just very similar to like a sausage casing. Okay.
对。我接受这个“扯淡”牌。谢谢。演得真好。谢谢。我们收到了来自俄勒冈州波特兰市的伊芙·H（Eve H.）的粉丝提问，她说：我奶奶在很多节日里都做过猪胃香肠。哦。她现在不做 了，因为她说这太费功夫了。
Which are made of intestines. So we eat that. Like if you've had a bratwurst, welcome to your intestine casing. But they just use a very clean portion of a pig's stomach, which is prepared in advance by a butcher. You can purchase these from butchers in many places in Pennsylvania, although it is sometimes just upon request. It's not like if you go to... Right, they don't have them ready to go. Right. Eve said that hogma is made mostly of sausage and potatoes. Some people also include vegetables.
但伊芙说，我可以打包票，这东西真的很好吃。那是什么？那是猪胃。好吧。里面塞满了东西。伊芙说，我知道猪胃的概念听起来很恶心，但它实际上非常类似于香肠肠衣。好吧。
Different family recipes feature slightly different variations on the ingredients, but in the end, they're all very similar. and potatoes. Some people also include vegetables. Different family recipes feature slightly different variations on the ingredients, but in the end, it's kind of like a very flavorful, steamy, potatoey meatloaf. I mean, that sounds good. Mm-hmm. Eve said the best way to cook it is a crock pot because then it keeps the casing, like the stomach, more edible because if you cook it, I guess, and it gets too dry, then the outside, it's hard to eat the outside and then you just eat the inside.
肠衣是用内脏做的。所以我们一直都在吃那个。就像如果你吃过德国小香肠（bratwurst），恭喜你吃过内脏肠衣。但他们只是用了猪胃非常干净的一个部分，由屠夫提前处理好。你可以在宾夕法尼亚州许多地方的屠夫那里买到这个，尽管有时需要预定。并不是说如果你去……对，他们不会准备好现货。对。伊芙说猪胃香肠主要是由香肠和土豆做成的。有些人还会加入蔬菜。
But it's really good when you can't eat the outside. But her grandma will not cook it anymore because the grandma says, quote, why take the time to stuff all the ingredients inside a raw pig's stomach when you can just cook sausage and potatoes in a pot and basically get the same dish? She's not wrong. She's not. I mean, it had a purpose at one point, probably. Yes. How you transport it or how it's contained or something.
不同的家庭食谱在配料上会有细微的差别，但总的来说，它们都非常相似。和土豆。有些人还会加入蔬菜。不同的家庭食谱在配料上会有细微的差别，但总的来说，它有点像非常入味、热气腾腾、满是土豆味的肉卷。我的意思是，听起来不错。嗯哼。伊芙说最好的烹饪方法是用慢炖锅，因为这样能保持肠衣，也就是胃的部分更可食，因为如果你煮的话，我猜，如果它变得太干，外面就会很难嚼，然后你只能吃里面的部分。
I'm sure it had a purpose. Yes. The stomach was an important element, but now we have things like crockpots. Yeah. Okay. Eve does have a question for us. And the question is, would you try hogma during your next visit to Pennsylvania? If you make it.
但当你咬不动外面时，里面的东西其实很好吃。但她奶奶再也不做了，因为奶奶说，原话是：“为什么要把所有配料塞进生猪胃里费这功夫，当你在锅里煮香肠和土豆基本上也能做出一样的菜呢？”她没说错。她确实没错。我的意思是，它在某个时候肯定有过它的用途。是的。比如你怎么运输它，或者它是怎么被包裹起来的之类的。
Yeah, would your grandma make us some hogma? Yeah, yeah. Could we come to your house? I would try your grandma's hogma. I would, too. I mean, we have it on good authority that it's delicious. Yes. I would. I would try it. I would try it. Yeah. Well, Eve, thank you it on good authority that it's delicious. Yes. I would. I would try it.
我确信它有它的用途。是的。胃是一个重要的元素，但现在我们有了慢炖锅这样的东西。对。好吧。伊芙确实有个问题要问我们。问题是，在你下次访问宾夕法尼亚州时，你会尝试猪胃香肠吗？如果你做的话。
I would try it. Yeah. Well, Eve, thank you so much for all of that hogma detail. I think we should take a break, Jenna, because when we come back, we have another 200th episode surprise. I'm excited about this one too. Yeah, me too. We are back and guess what everybody? We have something super special from our office ladies family. It's Dr. Tibideau.
对，你奶奶会给我们做一些猪胃香肠吗？对，对。我们可以去你家吗？我会尝尝你奶奶做的猪胃香肠。我也会。我的意思是，我们有权威消息证实它很好吃。是的。我会的。我会尝尝的。我会尝尝的。对。好吧，伊芙，非常感谢你提供所有关于猪胃香肠的细节。我觉得我们该休息一下了，詹娜，因为当我们回来时，我们还有另一个200集特别惊喜。我也对这个很兴奋。对，我也是。我们回来了，大家猜怎么着？我们收到了来自我们“办公室女士”大家庭的超级特别的东西。是蒂博代医生（Dr. Thibodeau）。
Yes, he reached out. He's got some stats and data tracking for us, but he also sent in a little video for us. You gotta hear it. Office ladies, this is Dr. Thibodeau. Congratulations on 200 episodes of your podcast. It's been a pleasure to be part of it since the 100th episode.
是的，他联系了我们。他给我们准备了一些统计数据和数据追踪，但他还给我们发了一小段视频。你们得听听这个。办公室女士们，我是蒂博代医生。祝贺你们的播客迎来第200集。自第100集以来能成为其中的一部分一直是我的荣幸。
I'm really excited to provide some more stats for you here today, and I look forward to at least 200 more episodes as you start this new network and new adventure. Congratulations. Awww. Didn't you love hearing his voice? I really did. Dr. Thibodeau went on to share, for your 200th episode, I'd like to share some new data I've
我很高兴今天能为你们提供更多统计数据，并且我期待在你们开启这个全新网络和全新冒险之际，能迎来至少另外200集。祝贺你们。噢。你们难道不觉得听到他的声音很亲切吗？我真的觉得很亲切。蒂博代医生接着分享道：为了你们的第200集，我想分享一些我一路走来
tracked along the way. So here are some key things that I've put together as fast stats. Fast stats. Yes, here is Dr. Thibodeau's fast stat number one. There have been over 474 fast facts so far. They have appeared in 158 episodes. While traditionally the episodes give three fast facts, Dr. Thibodeau noted that on nine occasions there was a bonus fast fact number four,
追踪到的新数据。所以这里有一些我整理出来的快速统计数据。快速统计数据。是的，这是蒂博代医生的第一条快速统计数据。到目前为止已经有超过474个快速事实了。它们出现在158集里。虽然传统上每集会提供三个快速事实，但蒂博代医生指出，有9次出现了第四个快速事实的彩蛋。
most notably in episode 90 when we learned that the stress release episode was the first time that the main titles featured the entire cast. That was a bonus fast fact. I just, I love everything he tracks. I love it so much. Fast stat number two, there have been 110 deep dives. Now, most episodes, you only get one deep dive. But there have been four episodes where we have given Angela as many as four deep dives.
最显著的是在第 90 集，我们了解到减压那一集是片头演职员表第一次出现全体演员。那是加码的快问速答。我就是、我太喜欢他追踪的一切了。我太喜欢了。第二个快问速答，一共有 110 次深度挖掘。通常情况下，每集只有一个深度挖掘。但有四集，我们给安吉拉安排了多达四个深度挖掘。
However, there have also been episodes with no deep dives. In fact, there were seven episodes without a single deep dive. Oh, deep dive drought. Yes. Dr. Thibodeau said, you've taught everyone so much, such as how to clean a microwave, all about cow butter sculptures at a state fair, and even why pancakes are round. I have to say, I'd forgotten about the cow butter sculptures. I hadn't forgotten about the cow butter, but I forgot about the pancakes.
不过，也有完全没有深度挖掘的集数。事实上，有七集连一次深度挖掘都没有。哦，深度挖掘荒。是的。蒂博代医生说，你们教了大家很多东西，比如如何清理微波炉、集市上的牛油雕塑，甚至还有煎饼为什么是圆的。我得说，我都忘了牛油雕塑这回事了。我没忘牛油的事，但我把煎饼的事给忘了。
Wow. You know, I thought I would never forget any of the deep dives, but I don't know. You know, my husband thinks we should have an episode with all the deep dives. Like best of deep dives? Best of deep dives, but I don't know. You know, my husband thinks we should have an episode with all the deep dives. Like best of deep dives? Best of deep dives, mm-hmm. It's not a bad idea. I know.
哇。你知道的，我以为我永远不会忘记任何深度挖掘，但说实话。你知道的，我丈夫认为我们应该做一集汇集所有深度挖掘的节目。比如深度挖掘精选？深度挖掘精选，但说实话。你知道的，我丈夫认为我们应该做一集汇集所有深度挖掘的节目。比如深度挖掘精选？深度挖掘精选，嗯哼。这主意不错。我知道。
I wanna do a book based on our deep dives. With all our extra time. We'll squeeze it in after carpool pickup. All right, here's another one. Also, I love that he labeled them Doctors Fast Stat. Yes. Doctors Fast Stat. Yes. Doctors Fast Stat number three. In episode 43, Ben Franklin,
我想以我们的深度挖掘为基础出一本书。用我们所有多余的时间。我们会在拼车接送的空隙里挤出时间。好了，这里还有另一个。还有，我喜欢他把这些标注为“医生快问速答”。是的。“医生快问速答”。是的。第三个“医生快问速答”。在第 43 集《本杰明·富兰克林》，
you introduce the world to the mom detectives, starting with the case of the garage massage. You presented us with 47 cases across 38 different episodes. That blows my mind. I know. 47 cases? We clearly love being mom detectives my mind. I know. 47 cases? We clearly love being mom detectives, lady.
你向世界介绍了妈妈侦探，从车库按摩案开始。你在 38 个不同的集数里向我们呈现了 47 个案件。这太让我震撼了。我知道。47 个案件？我们显然很热爱当妈妈侦探，我的天哪。我知道。47 个案件？我们显然很热爱当妈妈侦探，天哪，姐妹。
My gosh. He goes on to say, Angela and Jenna, y'all could be the next Agatha Christie. On Facebook, I once ran a March Madness challenge to crown the best mom detective story, and the undisputed winner was Knights of the Night Help the Mom Detectives from episode 145, Ultimatum. Thousands of votes were cast throughout the challenge and your fans are clearly passionate for mom detectives to come to life. The real mystery is how nobody in Hollywood has grabbed this idea and put the two of you on the screen together for this TV series.
天哪。他接着说，安吉拉和珍娜，你们俩完全可以成为下一个阿加莎·克里斯蒂。在脸书上，我曾经发起过一场疯狂三月挑战赛，来评选出最棒的妈妈侦探故事，毫无争议的赢家是第 145 集《最后通牒》里的“暗夜骑士协助妈妈侦探”。在整个挑战期间有成千上万的人投票，你的粉丝们显然对妈妈侦探走进现实充满热情。真正的谜团是，为什么好莱坞竟然没有人抓住这个创意，把你们俩一起弄上大银幕来拍这部电视剧。
It really is. It's just waiting to happen. I know. Again, if we just waiting to happen. I know. Again, if we just had more hours in our day. I know. You know what I mean? You know what? We just need someone to write it and then give us a call and we'll show up and do it.
确实如此。这只是时间问题。我知道。再说一次，如果我们只是时间问题。我知道。再说一次，如果我们只是有一点时间。我知道。你知道我的意思吗？你知道吗？我们只需要有人把它写出来，然后给我们打个电话，我们就会出现并把它拍出来。
That's what we need. We need someone to write it, develop it, sell it, make it. And then we'll show up. We'll show up. No problem. Mm-hmm, we're there. We're there. Doctors Fast Stat number four, in parentheses, he wrote bonus stat.
这就是我们需要的。我们需要有人写出来、开发它、把它卖出去、把它拍出来。然后我们就会出现。我们会出现的。没问题。嗯哼，我们随叫随到。我们随叫随到。第四个“医生快问速答”，在括号里，他写了“彩蛋统计”。
If you add up the time spent listening to your podcast just once, but hey, who can listen just once? Thank you. He put in parentheses. A person has spent nine and a half days of their life listening to Office Ladies. Well, actually, it's nine days, ten hours, forty-eight minutes, and forty-three seconds. But who's counting? Wow. We've made nine and a half days of content. Yeah.
如果你把听你们播客的时间加起来，哪怕只听一遍——但是，嘿，谁能只听一遍呢？谢谢。他在括号里写道。一个人花了他生命中九天半的时间来听《办公室女士》。好吧，实际上是九天十小时四十八分四十三秒。不过谁在数呢？哇。我们创造了九天半的内容。是的。
Well, you know, the first time we talked about Dr. Thibodeau was during our one hundredth episode, and he had tracked our use of the words amazing and lady. Oh no. Well, he's back again. Oh gosh. He said, we have now used the word amazing a total of 1,445 times. Amazing, there's another one for you.
好吧，你知道的，我们第一次谈论蒂博代医生是在我们的第一百集，当时他追踪了我们使用“amazing（太棒了）”和“lady（女士）”这两个词的频率。哦，不。好吧，他又回来了。哦天哪。他说，我们现在一共使用了 1,445 次“amazing”这个词。太棒了，这又是一个。
That's right. He should track that's right. I think I say that's right all the time. Well's right. He should track that's right. I think I say that's right all the time. Well, listen, you could track that one too. Meanwhile, we have a lot for you. We have said the word lady 1,276 times. No. That is a pace of 7.45 amazings and 6.3 ladies per episode.
没错。他应该追踪没错。我想我无时无刻不在说没错。好吧，没准儿。他应该追踪没错。我想我无时无刻不在说没错。好吧，听着，你也可以追踪那个。与此同时，我们有很多统计。我们已经说了 1,276 次“lady”这个词。不会吧。平均每集有 7.45 个“amazing”和 6.3 个“lady”。
And lastly, he says, just for Angela, because I did request this, he asked if we were curious about anything, he went and looked at the Instagram account for Office Ladies podcast. There have been 102 Insta stories and 305 Instagram feed posts. And I need everyone out there to know that those 102 Insta stories and 305 feed posts were all done by Angela Kinsey, our Instagram goddess. Oh gosh. You do all our Instagram, Angela, and you're so amazing at it. Every once in a while, you've needed me to post something
最后，他说，这只是为了安吉拉，因为我确实提出了这个请求，他问我们是否对任何事情感到好奇，于是他去查看了《办公室女士》播客的 Instagram 账号。一共有 102 条快拍和 305 条动态贴文。我需要让外面的所有人都知道，那 102 条快拍和 305 条动态贴文全都是由我们的 Instagram 女神安吉拉·金西完成的。哦天哪。安吉拉，我们的 Instagram 全是你弄的，而且你做得太棒了。每隔一段时间，当你需要我发点什么的时候，
and I have to dig out the password and figure out what I'm doing. But you always have it all ready for me anyway, but you're amazing. Round of applause to our Instagram. Thanks. Thanks. I love it. Your stories are always so creative.
我都得翻找密码，琢磨半天我在干什么。但无论如何，你总是帮我把一切都准备好，你真是太棒了。为我们的 Instagram 点赞。谢谢。谢谢。我太喜欢了。你的快拍总是极具创意。
I really enjoy doing it. I know. I don't know why I get such a kick out of it, but I do. Dr. Thibodeau also shared with us that our most popular post was from May 16, 2023. It had 264,956 likes. That post marked the 10th anniversary of the airing of the Office series finale. And our most popular reel was from April 26, 2023. It had 2.4 million views. Oh my gosh! Yeah, and over 200,000 likes. This was the post when Rainn Wilson joined us
我真的很喜欢做这个。我知道。我不知道为什么我从中得到那么多乐趣，但我确实乐在其中。蒂博代医生还跟我们分享说，我们最受欢迎的一篇贴文发布于 2023 年 5 月 16 日。它获得了 264,956 个赞。那篇贴文标志着《办公室》剧集大结局播出 10 周年。我们最受欢迎的短视频发布于 2023 年 4 月 26 日。它获得了 240 万次播放。哦天哪！是的，还有超过 20 万个赞。这就是雷恩·威尔逊加入我们
to record Search Committee Part 2, and we all talked about his book, Soul Boom. I love these stats! I know, wouldn't Rainn love to hear that? We'll have to share that with him. He would, we need to tell him that. Well, Dr. Thibodeau, thank you so much. This was such a treat. We just are so tickled by your tracking of things. Yes. You know, and then he signed off with the loveliest note, Angela.
来录制《搜寻委员会（下）》时的贴文，我们当时都聊了他的书《灵魂繁荣》。我太喜欢这些数据了！我知道，雷恩听到这些一定会很高兴吧？我们得跟他分享一下。他肯定会的，我们得告诉他。好吧，蒂博代医生，非常感谢。这真是一大惊喜。我们对你追踪数据的精神感到太开心了。是的。你知道的，然后他用最可爱的便条署名了，安吉拉。
He said, ladies, thank you for all you have given us through your rewatch podcast. Let's face it, you are each amazing. And we all look forward to so much more from you. I will continue to track data and stats for your show and I am at your service for any future stat needs. All my best, Dr. Peter Thibodeau. And he asked me if I would like any of his data or stats, like in a graph or any kind of visual and I said yes
他说，女士们，谢谢你们通过重播播客给我们带来的这一切。坦白说，你们每个人都非常棒。我们都期待着你们带来更多精彩。我将继续为你们的节目追踪数据和统计，随时听候你们对未来数据需求的调遣。祝一切都好，彼得·蒂博代医生。他还问我是否想要他的任何数据或统计资料，比如做成图表或任何形式的视觉效果，我说好。
And he's sending me stuff for our stories. Oh I love that All right, let's get back to this episode because Dwight is about to enter Dressed as belch nickel. Yeah judgment is nigh is Bel Schnickle. Yeah. Judgment is nigh. It's nigh. I want you guys to know that this costume was designed
而且他正在把东西发给我用于我们的快拍。哦，我太喜欢这个了。好了，让我们回到这一集，因为德怀特正要登场，打扮成贝尔施尼克。是的。审判即将来临。打扮成贝尔施尼克。是的。审判即将来临。审判即将来临。我想让你们知道，这套服装是
and built from scratch by our amazing costume designer, Alicia Raycraft. And when we were doing our book, I was going back and forth with her. We were doing research about the costuming department and its history for the book. And I said to her, I remember how you would build these costumes on the forms. Yeah, we would go into her office and on a mannequin, she would be building a costume.
由我们出色的服装设计师艾莉西亚·雷克拉夫特（Alicia Raycraft）从零开始设计和制作的。当我们在写书时，我一直在跟她来回沟通。为了这本书，我们在做关于服装部门及其历史的研究。我对她说，我还记得你是如何在人体模型上制作这些服装的。是的，我们会去她的办公室，她会在一个假人模特上制作服装。
Kind of like how you see them doing it on Project Runway, where they got a bunch of fabrics and their pieces and like clipping things. And I asked if she had any examples or any photos of a costume like that that she had done. And the photos she sent me were from this episode of Belchnickel. She sent a photo of her first drawing, her first artistic rendering idea. Which was so impressive. So impressive. She sent me pictures of the fabric
有点像你在《天桥骄傲》里看到的那样，他们有一堆布料和裁片，然后把东西夹起来。我问她是否有什么样本，或者她做过的类似服装的照片。她发给我的照片就是来自贝尔施尼克这一集。她发了一张她最初的草图、最初的艺术渲染构想的照片。非常令人印象深刻。非常令人印象深刻。她发给我一些布料的照片，
that she was draping on the form, and then a picture of the hat, which was a whole thing, and then a picture of it on rain. We featured these in the book. Yes, the Office BFFs. I'm going to share that in stories because it's really impressive to see. It really is.
那是她披在假人模型上的，然后是帽子的照片，那是个大工程，然后是穿在雷恩身上的照片。我们在书里收录了这些。是的，《办公室好闺蜜》。我会在快拍里分享这个，因为看到这些真的很震撼。确实如此。
Dwight shares that every year his grandfather would dress up as Belschnickle. And you know what? He was OK at it. Dwight says, every year his grandfather would dress up as Bilschnickle and you know what, he was okay at it. Dwight says, I am great. You know how they say some people were born to be bad? Well, I was born to be Bilschnickle. Well, we got a fan question from William M. in Sioux City, Iowa, slash Valencia, California, slash all over Florida, slash the United States Air Force. William, you've been a lot of places. William, I've been a lot of places. William, I see you. William wants to know,
德怀特分享说，他爷爷每年都会扮成贝尔施尼克。你知道吗？他演得还挺像那么回事。德怀特说，他爷爷每年都会扮成贝尔施尼克，你知道吗，他演得还挺像那么回事。德怀特说，我演得好极了。你知道他们怎么说的吗？有些人天生就是坏蛋？好吧，我天生就是贝尔施尼克。好吧，我们收到了来自艾奥瓦州苏城（斜杠）加利福尼亚州瓦伦西亚（斜杠）佛罗里达州各地（斜杠）美国空军的威廉·M. 的粉丝提问。威廉，你去过很多地方啊。威廉，我去过很多地方。威廉，我看到你了。威廉想知道，
did Dwight embellish Belchnickel at all or was the character played exactly as scripted? Well, here's how it was described in the script. There's not much. It just says, Dwight hobbles in costumed, a dirty hunched fur clad-jingling bearded traveler carrying a bundle of menacing tree branches, he shakes them. We also reached out to Rain and asked him
德怀特对贝尔施尼克有任何即兴发挥吗，还是这个角色完全是按照剧本演的？好吧，剧本里是这样描述的。没多少内容。上面只写着：德怀特一瘸一拐地盛装登场，一个肮脏、驼背、身穿皮草、浑身叮当响、留着胡子的旅行者，手里拿着一捆吓人的树枝，他摇晃着它们。我们还联系了雷恩，问了他
what it was like playing Belschnickle, and here's what he had to say. I just remember it was so much fun just kind of coming up with Dwight's version of the character of Belschnickle, the accent, which is absurd. It's a very strange accent, but his glee and delight at reenacting this kind of Christmas from his childhood, we get that nice peek into Dwight's childhood there, which was really fun.
扮演贝尔施尼克是什么感觉，他是这么说的。我只记得，想出德怀特版的贝尔施尼克这个角色真的太好玩了，那种口音简直荒谬。这是一种非常奇怪的口音，但他重现童年那种圣诞节时的狂喜和欢乐——我们在那里很好地窥探到了德怀特的童年，这真的很有趣。
And then there's such nice, like, emotional underpinnings of like, oh, Dwight's mad at Jim for leaving more because he's gonna miss him, you know, at the new job. And, you know, there's a love there, and there's a connection between Dwight and Pam, and there's some actual, like, subtext going on, which is not that common in primetime network television comedies. So that was nice to revisit.
然后还有非常棒的情感内核，比如，哦，德怀特生吉姆的气是因为吉姆要离职，因为他会想念吉姆的，你知道的，在新工作岗位上。而且，你知道的，这里面有一种爱，德怀特和帕姆之间有一种联系，还有一些真实的潜台词在进行，这在黄金时段电视网喜剧中并不常见。所以重新回顾这一段感觉很好。
Yeah, we just had a lot of fun. You know, what I love about Rain's answer is that it's just kind of reminding us that playing Bel Schnickle had these layers because he also still had to be Dwight, expressing all of his frustration, disappointment, love for Jim while also playing this character. So it was very layered. Very layered. And also he's probably vulnerable
是的，我们当时玩得很开心。你知道的，我喜欢雷恩的回答是因为它提醒了我们，扮演贝尔施尼克有着这些不同的层次，因为他同时还得是德怀特，表达他所有的沮丧、失望、对吉姆的爱，同时还要扮演这个角色。所以这是非常有层次感的。非常有层次感。而且他可能也很脆弱，
because he's sharing his family memories. Well, Dwight as Belschnickle now goes around the room. He says he's traveled from distant lands to discover how all the boys and girls have been behaving this year. Phyllis is going to say, oh, come on, Dwight, you're making this up. And Dwight says no. So Oscar looks it up on the internet. Oscar is always the one that looks up everything on the internet.
因为他在分享他的家庭记忆。好吧，化身贝尔施尼克的德怀特现在在房间里走来走去。他说他是从远方来的，来看看今年所有的男孩女孩表现得怎么样。菲利斯说，噢，拜托，德怀特，这是你瞎编的吧。德怀特说没有。于是奥斯卡在网上查了一下。奥斯卡总是那个在网上查阅一切的人。
Yes, he's our, like, what's the fact checker in real time? He's the fact checker. Oscar starts reading from his phone. He says, this is a real time. He's the fact checker. Oscar starts reading from his phone. He says, this is a real thing. Belschnickl is a crotchety fur-clad gift-giver related to the other companions of St. Nicholas in the folklore of southwestern Germany. Everyone reacts to this, and then Oscar continues reading. We learn that Belschnickl has a partner named Schwarty Pete, or Black Peter. He's often portrayed in colorful pantaloons and blackface.
是的，他是我们的，怎么说呢，实时事实核查员？他就是事实核查员。奥斯卡开始读手机上的内容。他说，这是一个实时。他就是事实核查员。奥斯卡开始读手机上的内容。他说，这确实是真的。贝尔施尼克是一个脾气暴躁、身穿皮草的送礼者，在德国西南部的民间传说中，他是圣尼古拉斯的其他同伴之一。大家对此做出反应，然后奥斯卡继续阅读。我们了解到贝尔施尼克有一个搭档叫施瓦蒂·皮特，也就是黑彼得。他通常被描绘成穿着色彩鲜艳的灯笼裤并涂着黑脸妆。
And Stanley's like, no, uh-uh Dwight, no. And Dwight says, come on, we don't blindly stick to every outmoded aspect of our traditions. So then we see Dwight, he immediately turns around and texts someone, and we never see who he texts or what happens. But in the original airing, you would have seen Nate down in the parking lot about to enter the building dressed as Black Peter, and Nate would have quickly turned around and not entered the building and left.
斯坦利说，不，呃-uh，德怀特，不行。德怀特说，拜托，我们可不会盲目固守传统中每一个过时的方面。于是我们看到德怀特立刻转身给某人发了条短信，我们从来不知道他发给谁或者发生了什么。但在最初播出时，你会看到内特在停车场准备进大楼，打扮成黑彼得的样子，内特会迅速转身，没有进大楼就离开了。
Yes, so this moment was cut from the episode in 2020. It was cut because it featured a character in Blackface. Greg Daniels put out a statement statement and here is what he said. He said, The office is about a group of people trying to work together with mutual respect, despite the inappropriate actions of their boss and assistant manager. The show employed satire to expose unacceptable behavior and deliver a message of inclusion. Today, we cut a shot of an actor wearing blackface that was used to criticize a specific racist
是的，所以在 2020 年，这个片段从这一集中被剪掉了。被剪掉是因为它出现了一个演员化着黑脸妆的角色。格雷格·丹尼尔斯发表了一份声明，他是这样说的。他说，《办公室》讲述了一群人试图在互相尊重的基础上一起工作的故事，尽管他们的老板和副经理有不当行为。这部剧运用讽刺来揭露不可接受的行为，并传递包容的信息。今天，我们剪掉了一个演员化着黑脸妆的镜头，该镜头原本用于批判一种特定的、带种族主义色彩的
European practice. Blackface is unacceptable and making the point so graphically is hurtful and wrong. I'm sorry for the pain that caused." Yeah, so that moment was cut. Yeah. You know, Andreas from Germany weighed in on Belschnickl and Black Pete. Andreas said, I come from a very German family, but I had not heard of Belschnickl before. So Andreas did a little deep dive and said that, yes,
欧洲习俗。黑脸妆是不可接受的，以如此直观的方式表达观点是伤害且错误的。我为它造成的痛苦感到抱歉。”是的，所以那一幕被剪掉了。是的。你知道的，来自德国的安德烈亚斯对贝尔施尼克和黑彼得发表了看法。安德烈亚斯说，我来自一个非常传统的德国家庭，但在那之前我没听说过贝尔施尼克。所以安德烈亚斯做了一点深入了解并说，是的，
Oscar is correct. It is a traditional character in Germany's southwestern regions. Belschnickl is a scary, furry man, sometimes even depicted as a monster. Oh. So Dwight's costume is quite on point. And like Oscar said, he is Santa Claus's companion. And as the tradition goes, on Christmas Eve, Santa Claus and Belschnickl will enter your living room together. They will ask your kids if they were well behaved over the last year. If they
奥斯卡说得对。这是德国西南部地区的传统角色。贝尔施尼克是一个可怕的、毛茸茸的男人，有时甚至被描绘成一个怪物。哦。所以德怀特的服装非常到位。就像奥斯卡说的，他是圣诞老人的同伴。按照传统，在平安夜，圣诞老人和贝尔施尼克会一起走进你的起居室。他们会问你的孩子过去一年表现好不好。如果他们
were nice, they get presents like apples and nuts from Santa Claus. If they were naughty, they would get a lump of coal and a whack from Belchnickle. Oh, wow. So the sticks were accurate, I guess, the whacking. So I guess in our Western traditions, Santa Claus is kind of both. You either get presents or coal. But their tradition is there's sort of good Santa and mean Santa. Yeah.
表现好，就会得到圣诞老人送的苹果和坚果等礼物。如果他们调皮捣蛋，就会得到一块煤炭和贝尔施尼克的棍棒伺候。哦，哇。所以这些树枝确实是真的，我想，挨打也是真的。所以我想在我们的西方传统中，圣诞老人有点兼顾这两者。要么得到礼物，要么得到煤炭。但他们的传统是，有点像好圣诞老人和坏圣诞老人。是的。
Now, Andreas went on to say, there is one detail in Oscar's explanation that's not quite correct. Black Pete is not a German Christmas tradition. It's actually a tradition in the Netherlands. Oh. So there you go. Well, Erin and Pete are now watching Die Hard
现在，安德烈亚斯接着说，奥斯卡的解释中有一个细节不太正确。黑彼得并不是德国的圣诞传统。这其实是荷兰的传统。哦。所以就是这样。好吧，现在艾琳和皮特正在安迪的办公室里看
in Andy's office. And in the background, Darryl is drinking the glue wine right out of the bowl. He's getting a little sloppy. He's really mad at Jim. He's like, you gotta stick to your word. Yeah. The rest of the bowl. He's getting a little sloppy. He's really mad at Jim. He's like, you got to stick to your word. Yeah. The rest of the evening is going to really take a turn for Daryl. In the conference room, we're all kind of sitting in a circle and it's time for Belchnickle to hand out gifts. So this whole exchange between Dwight and Phyllis about the set of bowls is my
《虎胆龙威》。背景里，达里尔正直接从大碗里喝着热红酒。他有点喝糊涂了。他真的很生吉姆的气。他心想，你得信守承诺。是的。碗里剩下的。他有点喝糊涂了。他真的很生吉姆的气。他心想，你得信守承诺。是的。接下来的整个晚上对达里尔来说将会有个巨大的转变。在会议室里，我们都围坐成一圈，轮到贝尔施尼克发礼物了。所以德怀特和菲利斯关于这套碗的整个对话是我
favorite moment in the whole entire episode. I know. Because it just reminded me of my husband. If you borrow Tupperware from us, he's going to expect it back with the correct lid. He would also be like, these bowls are a set. These aren't the gift. Yes. No, I love it.
整集里最喜欢的时刻。我知道。因为这让我想起了我丈夫。如果你从我们这儿借了特百惠保鲜盒，他就会期望你把正确的盖子一起还回来。他也会觉得：这些碗是一整套的。这些可不是送的礼物。是的。不，我太喜欢了。
He's handed out these really beautiful wooden bowls that everyone wants to keep. But you can't keep them. Belchnickle's actually going to put your gift in the bowl once he's determined that you're admirable. Only if you're admirable do you get a gift in the bowl, but the bowl is not your gift. He needs them all back. They're a set.
他分发了这些非常漂亮的木碗，每个人都想据为己有。但你不能留着。一旦贝尔施尼克确定你令人钦佩，他实际上会把你的礼物放进碗里。只有当你令人钦佩时，你才能在碗里得到礼物，但这个碗可不是送给你的礼物。他需要把它们全部收回来。这是一套的。
And if you're impish, you're going to get hit with those sticks. Yes. I have an unpopular opinion to share. Oh, let's hear it. Maybe it's unpopular, maybe it's popular. We'll see. Oh my god, I don't even know if I can say it. I don't want people to turn on me.
如果你淘气，你就会挨那些棍子打。是的。我有一个不受欢迎的观点要分享。哦，说来听听。也许它不受欢迎，也许它很受欢迎。我们走着瞧。哦天哪，我甚至不知道我能不能说。我可不想人们反感我。
Oh, is this like a Star Wars moment? No, it's... Ah, it's just, you know, I think people are so hard on Pam in this season, but I don't, I don't love Jim in this episode. Oh, and I don't love this storyline for Jim and Pam in this episode. I remember struggling with it a little bit at the time.
哦，这就像《星球大战》的时刻吗？不，这……啊，这只是，你知道的，我觉得人们在这季里对帕姆太严苛了，但我并不、在这集里我不太喜欢吉姆。哦，而且在这集里我也不喜欢吉姆和帕姆这条故事线。我记得当时看的时候就觉得有点难受。
I don't like how Jim is heckling Dwight in this moment. I don't like that they've set up this whole dream of Dwight's to come true just so that they can kind of like just— Poke fun at it? Yeah, just— It's kind of mean. I think it's mean. Yeah.
我不喜欢吉姆此刻在对德怀特起哄。我不喜欢他们把德怀特的整个梦想变成现实，结果却只是为了——取笑它？是的，只是——这有点刻薄。我觉得这很刻薄。是的。
And mean-spirited and— They're kind of being bratty. Yeah, they're being jerks. But I'm sorry, I think in particular Jim. And it was hard for me as Pam, who has a soft spot for Dwight, to find a way to do this thing for her husband that was resulting in her friend getting made fun of. Yeah. And I just, I didn't like the snickering. I didn't like what I also sort of saw as kind of this like smug, too cool for school kind
而且充满恶意，还——他们有点像被惯坏的小孩。是的，他们像混蛋。但抱歉，尤其是吉姆，我觉得是这样。作为对德怀特心存柔情的帕姆，要设法为丈夫做这件事，而结果却是自己的朋友遭到嘲笑，这对我来说很难。是的。而且我就是，我不喜欢那种窃笑。我也不喜欢我所看到的、吉姆身上那种自以为是、自命不凡的
of vibe. That was that Jim had. That was coming from Jim. Sorry. I can see all that. I can see it. Yeah. It was hard. It was, I didn see all that. I can see it. Yeah. It was hard.
氛围。那是吉姆散发出来的。抱歉。我能理解这一切。我能看出来。是的。这很难。这，我没能理解这一切。我能看出来。是的。这很难。
It was, I didn't like it. I didn't find Jim likable in this storyline. Also just like, why haven't you said anything to Daryl? Right? Like, Jim's very self-involved. Very self-involved. You know what? He's having that moment where he has this new thing that is really distracting him and occupying all of his space and also maybe making him lose
这，我不喜欢。在这条故事线里，我觉得吉姆一点也不讨人喜欢。还有，就像，你为什么什么都没对达里尔说？对吧？吉姆这个人太自我了。太自我了。你知道吗？他正经历着这样一个阶段：他有一件新事物，这让他严重分心，占据了他所有的精力，甚至可能让他忽视了
sight on the people that matter around him. He's just having his little selfish chapter here. He is. And we all have them in our lives. We do. So I am able to. Yeah. We've all had moments where we get so consumed by something
身边的重要人物。他只是在这里度过他那自私的小篇章。他确实是。我们在生活中都会遇到这样的人。我们会的。所以我能够理解。是的。我们都曾有过这样的时刻：我们被某件事消耗得精疲力竭，
and then we come out of the fog and we're like, oh, I was kind of a turd back then. I'm sorry. Yes, and that's okay because he'll come out of the fog. You got to come out of the fog. Stop being a turd. Yes. Well, Jim is going to realize now, oh my gosh, I have to go.
然后从迷雾中清醒过来，心想：哦，我那时候简直是个混蛋。我很抱歉。是的，没关系的，因为他会走出迷雾的。你得走出迷雾。别再当个混蛋了。是的。好吧，吉姆现在要意识到，哦天哪，我得走了。
I have to go to Philly. And both Pam and Dwight are taking a back. They're like, oh my gosh, I have to go. I have to go to Philly. And both Pam and Dwight are taken aback. They're like, oh my gosh, already? What? They're both bummed out in their own different ways. Yeah. But before he leaves, Belschnickle needs to judge if he was impish or admirable, and guess what he was? Jim was impish. So impish. So impish. We got a fan question from Ty B in Calgary, Alberta. When Dwight was whacking Jim with the stick, is he actually hitting him?
我得去费城了。帕姆和德怀特都大吃一惊。他们心想：哦天哪，我得走了。我得去费城了。帕姆和德怀特都大吃一惊。他们心想：哦天哪，这么快？什么？他们都以各自不同的方式感到沮丧。是的。但在他离开之前，贝尔施尼克需要评判他今天是淘气还是值得钦佩，你猜他怎么样？吉姆很淘气。太淘气了。太淘气了。我们收到了来自艾伯塔省卡尔加里的泰伊·B. 的粉丝提问。当德怀特用棍子打吉姆时，他是真的在打吗？
It looks so real. Yeah. Yeah. I really remember it. I remember the pieces of the stick breaking off as Rain whacked him with that. I did too. When I watched the scene, I was like,
看起来太逼真了。是的。是的。我真的记得。我还记得雷恩用棍子打他时，棍子的碎片都断裂飞出去了。我也是。当我看到这一幕时，我想：
oh yeah, remember how hard he was hitting him? I will tell you, there's a moment, and you can see, it's truly honest, where John is like, okay, enough! Yes, I saw it too. Well, we asked Rain if he remembered this scene, and here is what he said. You know, the number one thing that I remember is, like, I was infamous for hurting people on the set.
哦，对啊，还记得他当时打得有多狠吗？我告诉你，有一个时刻，你可以看出来，那是完全真实的，约翰当时说：好了，够了！是的，我也看到了。好吧，我们问了雷恩是否还记得这一幕，他是这么说的。你知道的，我记得最清楚的一件事是，我在片场可是出了名的会弄伤人。
At one point, I had thrown a mini barbell up in the air and it hit. I had Robinson in the head and gave him a bump the size of a golf ball. You know, I'd thrown a snowball in John's face. I'd knocked sand into Leslie's eyes. Everyone had some way, shape or form had been hurt by rain glaying Dwight in some way, shape or form. So I knew, oh jeez, I've got to literally whip people with a straw baton. Someone's going to get their eye gouged out. So probably I hit John too many times and too hard. And I think a couple of times I tried to hit him in the groinal area, just on purpose, just because it was so much fun. I would like to just get a little,
有一次，我把一个迷你杠铃往空中一扔，它砸中了。砸中了罗宾逊的脑袋，鼓起了一个高尔夫球大小的包。你知道的，我往约翰脸上砸过雪球。我把沙子弄进莱斯利眼里。每个人都以这样或那样的方式被雷恩扮演的德怀特弄伤过。所以我当时心想，哦天哪，我得真拿一根稻草棒去抽人了。别把谁的眼睛给戳瞎了。所以可能我打约翰的次数太多了，下手也太重了。而且我想我有好几次故意想往他的下三路招呼，纯粹就是因为太好玩了。我只想从他身上得到一点点，
little reaction out of out of him. So I was very wary and careful around that. Well, Ray and I remember all those same things. I do too. I like how you said, Rayne, that you were very careful around that area, but you still tried to hit it. Yes, that's right. Well, lady, before we move on, my neighbor is such a big fan of the show and wanted to make a message for us. I hope that's okay. He's such a huge fan and we'll hear.
一点点反应。所以我当时对那个区域非常警惕和小心。好吧，雷恩，我记得所有这些相同的事。我也是。我喜欢你刚才说的，雷恩，你说你对那个区域非常小心，但你还是试图去打它。是的，没错。好吧，姐妹，在我们继续之前，我的邻居是这部剧超级无敌的粉丝，想给我们录一段话。希望这没问题。他是如此巨大的粉丝，我们听听吧。
You have to hear it. Hey, Jenna. Hi, Angela. Happy 200th episode. What a fantastic milestone. Well, cool beans and congratulations, girls. Oh my gosh. I did not know what to expect when you set that up.
听听看。嘿，珍娜。嗨，安吉拉。祝贺第 200 集。多么了不起的里程碑。太棒了，祝贺你们，姑娘们。哦天哪。我完全没想到你会有这出。
I know, your face, you were like, what? Because I know I saw you doing that thing in your brain of like, who, what, what neighbor? I thought it was gonna be like a kid or somebody who lives in your neighborhood and it was the biggest kid of all, who, what, what neighbor? Like, what? I thought it was gonna be like a kid or somebody who lives in your neighborhood and it was the biggest kid of all, Creed. Creed, who lives at the end of my street. Aw.
我知道，看你的表情，你当时心想：什么？因为我知道我看到你脑子在飞速运转：谁？什么？哪个邻居？我还以为会是个小孩或者住在你附近的人呢，结果竟然是最大的“小孩”——谁？什么？哪个邻居？就像：什么？我还以为会是个小孩或者住在你附近的人呢，结果竟然是最大的“小孩”，奎迪。奎迪，就住在我的街尾。啊。
He's been so supportive of the podcast and he wanted to wish us happy 200th. I love that. Well, now Pam is gonna walk Jim to his cab. She's like, this is it. I can't believe it's actually happening. And Jim says, thanks for putting together such a great last Christmas party.
他一直非常支持这个播客，他想祝我们第 200 集快乐。我太喜欢了。好吧，现在帕姆要送吉姆去坐出租车。她心想：就是这样。我不敢相信这一切真的发生了。吉姆说：谢谢你把最后一次圣诞派对办得这么棒。
I felt that on two levels. I was like, this is it. This is the last Christmas party. Yeah, he also makes a joke and he's like, well, I guess this is goodbye. You know, I'll never see you again or something like that. I can't remember the exact joke. And Pam's like, come on, I'm trying to be serious here.
我在两个层面上感受到了这一点。我当时心想：就是这样。这是最后一次圣诞派对。是的，他还开玩笑说，嗯，我想这就是永别了。你知道的，我再也见不到你了或者类似的话。我不记得具体笑话是什么了。帕姆说：拜托，我正经着呢。
Yeah. Yeah. And I felt like this was another moment that we were trying to play to show how Jim's head is a little bit in the clouds. He's enamored with the new job. He's having that selfish time. And he's not seeing Pam. He's not registering last Christmas party and like the look on her face. He's not registering like the separation of their family so that this job can happen. Yes. And also, I don't know if you noticed, but Pam says, I love you as he's getting into the cab and he's like, Oh yeah, I love you too. It's like, everything is a real afterthought for Jim here. And it's meant to be kind of to show like, oh, wow,
是的。是的，我觉得这是另一个想要展现吉姆的心思有点飘忽不定的时刻。他被新工作迷住了。他正在经历那段自私的时光。他没有注意到帕姆。他没有意识到这是最后一次圣诞派对，也没有注意到她脸上的表情。他没有意识到为了让这份工作成行，他们的家庭即将面临分离。是的。而且，我不知道你有没有注意到，当吉姆上车时帕姆说“我爱你”，他回答说：“哦，是的，我也爱你。”感觉对吉姆来说，一切在这里都成了马后炮。而这本来就是为了表现——哦，哇，
they are in different spaces right now. Yeah. Well, Pam is going to very sadly walk back into the office. And Dwight has been watching all of this from the window. Well, as Pam's going up to the office, Dwight is on his way out. He's taken all of his decorations down. He's like, you know what?
他们现在处在不同的世界里。是的。好吧，帕姆带着无限伤感走回了办公室。德怀特把这一切都从窗户里看在眼里。好吧，当帕姆走向办公室时，德怀特正准备离开。他把自己所有的装饰都扯了下来。他心想：你知道吗？
You bell on Christmas, Christmas bells on you. And guess what? Bell Schnigel isn't real. It's me, Dwight. Yeah. He's hurt. He is. But the Christmas party is going to continue
你们这些圣诞节的铃铛，圣诞铃铛都见鬼去吧。还有，猜怎么着？贝尔施尼克根本不是真的。是我，德怀特。是的。他受伤了。他是。但圣诞派对还将继续，
because Phyllis finds some old decorations in the warehouse. Oscar ran to the store for food and drinks. And Phyllis says, guess what? I guess they needed me after all. Mm-hmm. And lady, I have to share with you. I have a little call sheet tidbit here. I think I know what this call sheet tidbit is.
因为菲利斯在仓库里找到了一些旧装饰。奥斯卡跑去商店买吃的喝了。菲利斯说：猜怎么着？我猜他们最终还是需要我的。嗯哼。姐妹，我得跟你分享一下。我这里有一个通告单的小八卦。我想我知道这个通告单八卦是什么。
Yes. The Dunder Mifflin crew is decorating for Christmas, but in real life on our set, it was Halloween. Halloween was this week. This used to happen all the time. When we would shoot our Christmas episode, it would be Halloween week in real life. This has happened more than once.
是的。邓德米夫林的员工们在为圣诞节做装饰，但在现实中我们的片场却是万圣节。这周正好是万圣节。这种事以前经常发生。当我们拍摄圣诞特辑时，现实生活中往往正是万圣节周。这种事发生不止一次了。
Yeah. And boy, did our cast and crew love Halloween. I mean, I shared in last week's episode, there was a countdown on the call sheets to Halloween. Well, Steve Burr just sent me the call sheet for October 31st. We were filming. I printed it out. I'm going to share it. Someone was having a lot of fun with this call sheet, lady. sheet for October 31st. We were filming. I printed it out. I'm going to share it. Someone was having a lot of fun with this call sheet, lady. First of all, normally on a call sheet, it tells you the crew call and what time everyone's called to set. On this one, it says the bewitching hour and the spooky call. And then normally we have a message if there's going to be an
是的，天哪，我们的演员和剧组是多么热爱万圣节啊。我的意思是，我在上周的节目里分享过，通告单上有个倒计时直奔万圣节。好吧，史蒂夫·伯格刚刚发给我 10 月 31 日的通告单。我们当时在拍戏。我把它打印出来了。我要分享一下。有人拿着这通告单玩得不亦乐乎呢，姐妹。10 月 31 日的通告单。我们当时在拍戏。我把它打印出来了。我要分享一下。有人拿着这通告单玩得不亦乐乎呢，姐妹。首先，通常在通告单上，它会告诉你剧组集合时间和每个人被叫到片场的时间。在这张上面，写的是“巫术时刻”和“诡异集合”。然后通常如果片场会有
on-set photographer and it will say NBC still photographer on set today. But on this call sheet announcement, it said that NBC still coroner will be on set today. There's also announcement that the Halloween costume contest will be at lunch. And then if you go to the back of the call sheet for all of the different crew categories, they were changed to different names.
剧照摄影师，就会写着“NBC 剧照摄影师今天在片场”。但在这次的通告单公告上，它写的是“NBC 剧组法医今天将在片场”。上面还宣布万圣节服装比赛将在午餐时间举行。然后如果你翻到通告单背面针对所有不同剧组部门的部分，它们的名字全被改掉了。
For example, instead of saying hair and makeup with everyone's call times, it says morticians. Oh! There's the headhunters, there's the groundskeepers, there's the bloody heart department, the grave robbers, the flamethrowers, the office of the recently deceased. Amazing. Amazing.
比如，上面没有写带着各自集合时间的“发型和化妆”，而是写了“殡仪馆”。哦！还有“赏金猎人”、“看门人”、“流血的心部门”、“盗墓贼”、“喷火兵”、“近期去世人员办公室”。太棒了。太棒了。
And in the transportation department, they were labeled instead of transportation, hearses. I mean, someone was just having a really good time with all of this and I'm gonna share it. It's really fun. Well, I remember this Halloween because my son was a year old
在交通运输部门，他们没有被称为运输部，而是被标为“灵车”。我的意思是，有人把这一切玩得太开心了，我要把它分享出来。真的太有趣了。好吧，我记得这个万圣节，因为我儿子当时一岁，
and we were gonna dress him up as a Wimbledon tennis player. Yeah, I remember. We had gone a Wimbledon tennis player. Yeah, I remember. We had gone to Wimbledon when I was pregnant and we had gotten a teeny baby size Wimbledon shirt. It was white. And we were like, oh, this is such a good costume because he can wear the shirt.
我们打算把他打扮成温网网球运动员。是的，我记得。我们去了温网网球运动员。是的，我记得。我怀孕时去过温网，我们买了一件微型婴儿尺码的温网衬衫。是白色的。我们当时想，哦，这服装太棒了，因为他可以穿这件衬衫。
He can wear the little white shorts, right? And little hat, little shoes. And I was like, oh, I wanna get him like a little tennis racket, like a little toy tennis racket. Well, I couldn't find any that were like the right size for him. Sure, they're also big. Yeah. So I was just chatting with Phil Shea,
他可以穿白色的小短裤，对吧？还有小帽子、小鞋子。然后我想，哦，我想给他弄个小网球拍，比如一个小玩具网球拍。好吧，我找不到任何适合他那个尺寸的。当然，那些都太大了。是的。所以我当时正在跟菲尔·谢伊聊天，
the amazing Phil Shea, and I said, Phil, what would you do if you had to get like a tiny tennis racket for like a one-year-old? Like, where would you get that? Sure. Where can you point me in the right direction? And he said, Jenna, I got it, I'll get you one. I'll get you one. I'm like, no, no, no, I'll do it.
了不起的菲尔·谢伊，我对他说：菲尔，如果你得给一个一岁左右的小孩弄个微型网球拍，你会怎么做？比如你去哪儿能弄到？当然。你能给我指条明路吗？他说：珍娜，包在我身上，我给你弄一个。我给你弄一个。我说：不，不，不，我自己来。
Like you don't need anything more to do. Just tell me where to go. He was like, no, I'll get it. I'll get it for you. I got it, I got it. I was like, okay. This was like a few weeks before Halloween. For Halloween, Angela, Phil Shea presented me
就像你不需要揽更多活了。只要告诉我该去哪儿就行。他说：不，我来弄。我给你弄。包在我身上，包在我身上。我说：好吧。这大约是万圣节前几周。到了万圣节那天，安吉拉，菲尔·谢伊送给了我
with a tiny tennis racket, lady. It was not a toy. I remember. It was a tiny, real tennis racket. He had someone make your son a real teeny tiny, real racket with strings and everything. Yes, with a teeny tiny tennis bag. Oh my gosh, it was the cutest thing.
一把微型网球拍，姐妹。那可不是玩具。我记得。那是一把微型、真正的网球拍。他让人给我儿子定制了一把真正的、超迷你的真球拍，上面有网线和一切。是的，还有一个超迷你的网球包。哦天哪，这简直是太可爱了。
I was like, Phil, what is this? I was like, what have you done? And he was just smiling. He was so delighted. I have all these pictures. I mean, this tennis racket made the outfit. It was the sweetest thing. And you know, guys, we all gathered recently
我当时说：菲尔，这是什么？我说：你这是干了什么？他只是在微笑。他高兴坏了。我有所有这些照片。我的意思是，这把网球拍让整套服装完美了。这简直太甜了。你知道吗，伙计们，我们最近聚在一起
for a celebration of life for Phil. All of our crew came and celebrated him, the crews of other shows he had worked on. It was so wonderful to see how many lives Phil touched. It was so bittersweet, but also so special to see our crew and to spend time with them and to share our memories of Phil. Yeah, and this was a story that I told
为菲尔举行了一场生命礼赞。我们所有的剧组人员都来纪念他，还有他工作过的其他剧组的人。看到菲尔触动了那么多人的生命，真的太美妙了。这真是苦乐参半，但能见到我们的剧组并和他们共度时光、分享我们对菲尔的回忆，又是如此特别。是的，这就是我讲述的一个故事，
because it's so very Phil. Yeah. Yeah, so I remember this and I have pictures. I do too. I love the pictures from this Halloween and also Steve Burgess shared some of his photos from the Halloween costume contest. Our crew would often coordinate costumes and so there was a group this year I remember
因为这太有菲尔的风格了。是的。是的，所以我记得这个，而且我有照片。我也是。我太喜欢这次万圣节的照片了，而且史蒂夫·伯格还分享了一些他拍摄的万圣节服装比赛的照片。我们的剧组经常会协调服装，所以今年我记得有一组人
who did Scooby Doo. They were so creative. I have a photo that I love of my daughter and your son on set together. He's in his tennis outfit. And you would never know this because she's just in a pink shirt and pink leggings, but she was a cupcake, like a paper mache cupcake that you step into. But she got tired of wearing it. So she took it off. She was just the underneath part. Yeah. But they were a cupcake and a tennis player. This was a really special episode. Everyone brought their kids.
扮成了《史酷比》。他们太有创意了。我有一张我女儿和你儿子在片场合影的照片，我特别喜欢。他穿着网球服。你绝对猜不到，因为她只穿着粉色衬衫和粉色打底裤，但她其实是个纸浆彩饰蛋糕，就是那种你得站进去的纸杯蛋糕。但她穿腻了。所以她把它脱掉了。她只留了里面的部分。是的。但他们一个是纸杯蛋糕，一个是网球运动员。这真的是非常特别的一集。大家都把孩子带来了。
It was really special. It was our last Christmas episode and our last Halloween parade all in one. Yep. Nellie hears the party starting, but Toby is still sharing with her about his jury experience. There's a great montage in the bullpen
真的很特别。这是我们的最后一个圣诞特辑，也是我们的最后一个万圣节游行，合二为一了。没错。内莉听到派对开始了，但托比还在跟她滔滔不绝地讲他的陪审团经历。办公区里有一个精彩的蒙太奇镜头，
of people starting to have a good time. At 16 minutes, 33 seconds. Did anyone else catch Brian as Kevin lifting me off the credenza? Yes! And almost dropping me? What was that? We just improvised that.
人们开始玩得很开心。在 16 分钟 33 秒处。有没有人注意到布赖恩饰演的凯文把我和证物柜一起抱起来了？是的！差点把我摔了？那是什么情况？那是我们即兴发挥的。
I was supposed to be up there hanging decorations and I legitimately couldn't get down and needed help. And Brian thought it would be funny to kind of clumsily get me down from there. It looks like also Kevin got his wish. He is Santa. That's right. Darryl is really hitting that punch bowl hard and getting more and more drunk. Dwight is going to return. He's in his own clothes. And Pam says, you know, for the record, I liked your party better.
我本来应该在那上面挂装饰品，但我实在下不去了，需要人帮忙。布赖恩觉得笨手笨脚地把我从上面弄下来会挺搞笑的。看起来凯文也如愿以偿了。他就是圣诞老人。没错。达里尔真的在疯狂痛饮那个潘趣酒碗，醉得越来越厉害。德怀特回来了。他穿着自己的衣服。帕姆说：你知道的，说实话，我更喜欢你的派对。
Yeah, they're kind of commiserating, but they're going to go ahead and, you know, participate in the party when all of a sudden, surprise, surprise, who walks in the door? Jim. Jim? Yeah. Jim is back. What's going on?
是的，他们有点在同病相怜，但他们还是决定去参加派对，就在这时，突发奇想，谁走进门来？吉姆。吉姆？是的。吉姆回来了。怎么回事？
Turns out. He missed his wife. Yeah. And he also found out there's a bus at 5 a.m. Why is he taking the bus? I don't know. They have two cars. I don't know. Does he two cars. I don't know.
原来。他想念他老婆了。是的。而且他还发现早上 5 点有一班长途汽车。他为什么坐长途汽车？我不知道。他们有两辆车。我不知道。难道他
Does he not need a car when he's there? Maybe he doesn't have a parking spot. Is it hard to park in Philly? I mean, he could just get there faster in his own car. I don't know. And then he would have a car. And guys, it's not that far away. I know.
在那边不需要车吗？也许他没有停车位。在费城停车很难吗？我的意思是，他完全可以自己开车更快地到达那里。我不知道。而且那样他就有车了。而且伙计们，那其实并不远。我知道。
I mean, frankly, he could drive there in the morning, get his workday done and drive home. He could be a commuter. Yes. People do that all the time. All the time. Well, Dwight is so happy. Pam is so happy.
我的意思是，坦白说，他完全可以早上开车过去，完成一天的工作再开车回家。他完全可以当个通勤族。是的。人们经常这么做。经常这样。好吧，德怀特太高兴了。帕姆太高兴了。
Dwight wants to compete for the big piece of the pig rib with Jim. Jim wins, and oh, gosh, this was disgusting. What was it? I don't know. It was like the wishing bone was like covered in, I don't know. It looked like some kind of Grothy gravy gravy and it looks gross. It splatters all over everyone I wouldn't want that
德怀特想跟吉姆争夺猪肋骨的最大一块。吉姆赢了，哦，天哪，这太恶心了。那是什么？我不知道。那感觉就像许愿骨上面裹着，我不知道。看起来像是某种黏糊糊的肉汁，看起来真恶心。它溅到了每个人身上，我可不想要那玩意儿。
Wouldn't want that either. I mean, you know, I don't want a pie in the face I don't want you to smush my wedding cake in my face. No, don't do that to me. I don't want you to throw gravy on me. Please don't throw gravy on me. Daryl sees Jim and oh my gosh, he is ticked off. He's gonna charge towards Jim and let him have it. And Jim's like, hey, I talked to the guys about hiring you and they wanna set up an interview.
我也不想要那个。我的意思是，你知道的，我不想要派砸在脸上，我也不希望你把我的结婚蛋糕糊在我的脸上。不，别对我这么做。我可不想你把肉汁泼在我身上。请千万别把肉汁泼在我身上。达里尔看到吉姆了，哦天哪，他气炸了。他要冲向吉姆，给他好看。吉姆说：嘿，我跟那帮人提过雇佣你的事了，他们想安排一次面试。
Daryl's like, what? Oh my gosh, great. He does this like woo-boo spin move and completely crashes into the food table. We had a fan question from Kelly Kay in St. Louis, Missouri who said, I need to know every detail about Darrell falling on the table because it's one of my favorite moments of the whole series.
达瑞尔就说，什么？哦天哪，太棒了。他做了个类似乌布旋转的动作，直接撞到了餐桌上。我们收到了来自密苏里州圣路易斯的凯利·凯的粉丝提问，她说，我需要知道达瑞尔摔在桌子上的每一个细节，因为这是整部剧我最喜欢的时刻之一。
The spin before he falls, the table breaking twice, everyone's screaming. It just cracks me up every single time I watch. Well Steve Burgess said we had a special breakaway table built. Our stunt coordinator, Brett Jones, worked out the fall with Craig. Craig really did it himself. That was not a stunt person. I think you can tell.
摔倒前的旋转，桌子碎了两次，所有人都尖叫起来。每次我看都觉得超级搞笑。史蒂夫·伯吉斯说我们特意定制了一张易碎桌。我们的特技协调员布雷特·琼斯和克雷格一起排练了这个摔倒动作。克雷格真的是自己完成的。那不是替身。我想大家一眼就能看出来。
Yep. And Steve said we were prepared to do two takes. We had two breakaway tables, but Craig nailed it on the first go, so we only had to do the one. Angela, we also had a fan catch in this scene from Anna W. in Edmond, Oklahoma. Edmond, Oklahoma? I was just there.
没错。史蒂夫说我们准备拍两遍。我们准备了两张易碎桌，但克雷格一次就成功了，所以我们只拍了一条。安吉拉，我们还在这一幕里收到了来自俄克拉荷马州埃德蒙的安娜·W的粉丝截图。俄克拉荷马州埃德蒙？我刚去过那里。
You were? Yeah, Josh's sister lives there. Does she know Anna W.? I don't know. We'll have to find out. What's up, Anna? Well, Anna says between 19 and 20 minutes we catch a glimpse of Phyllis at the party wearing
你去过？对，乔治的妹妹住在那里。她认识安娜·W吗？我不知道。我们得打听一下。安娜，怎么回事？安娜说，在19到20分钟之间，我们瞥见菲莉丝在派对上穿着
a fur coat. Was there a side story that explains why she's wearing a fur coat? Oh Anna I got you covered. Alright so there was a montage of the Christmas party where everyone was having a good time right? I mentioned that? Yes. Well it's longer and in extended, it's in deleted scenes. And Bob Vance gives Phyllis her Christmas present. Again, why at the work party? This happens sometimes. It does. We get big gifts at these parties. Yes.
一件皮草大衣。有没有什么支线故事解释她为什么穿皮草大衣？哦，安娜，这题我会。好吧，圣诞派对上有一个蒙太奇镜头，大家都在玩得很开心，对吧？我提到过吗？是的。其实这个片段更长，在剪辑版和删减片段里。鲍勃·万斯送给菲莉丝圣诞礼物。等等，为什么要在工作派对上送？有时候确实会这样。确实会。我们在这些派对上也会收到大礼。没错。
And it's a fur coat. And he wraps her in it and then they snuggle. She's so happy. Also in this scene, Creed is walking around with a tray of hot chocolate and tapas. Oh, I love that. This is how the scene was described in the shooting draft. The office is decorated in a slapdash fashion for a last second Christmas party. The table is laden with food and drink, a few strings of lights, Christmas music, people are having fun. Phyllis, Angela, and Oscar look around at their handiwork and are proud. People start taking shots. Creed hands out hot chocolate and tapas. Bob Vance watches Phyllis open her gift, a luxurious mink coat. It takes her breath away. Oscar gives Angela a gift.
是一件皮草大衣。他把大衣裹在她身上，然后他们依偎在一起。她太高兴了。另外在这场戏里，克里德端着一盘热巧克力和西班牙小吃四处走动。哦，我太喜欢了。拍摄剧本里是这样描述这一幕的：办公室为最后一刻的圣诞派对草草装扮了一番。桌上摆满了食物和饮料，挂着几串彩灯，放着圣诞音乐，大家玩得很开心。菲莉丝、安吉拉和奥斯卡环顾四周，对他们的劳动成果感到自豪。大家开始敬酒。克里德分发热巧克力和西班牙小吃。鲍勃·万斯看着菲莉丝打开礼物，一件奢华的水貂大衣。这让她惊艳不已。奥斯卡送给安吉拉一份礼物。
What? Remember how earlier in the episode we talked about how he's trying to win her favor? Yes. Angela opens a hand-knitted Snuggie for a cat and it cuts to Oscar. He says, I made a Snuggie for Pebbles. I know she gets cold at night. In the background, Angela gives Oscar the slightest nod of appreciation. Pebbles. This is a new cat reveal. Is this the first reference to a pebbles? Yes. Pebbles. There you go. Was that on our list of cats with Billie Eilish or no, because it didn't actually live in the episode? I don't think so, because this is in a deleted scene. Okay. Billie Eilish, if you're listening, please note
什么？还记得我们之前在剧集里讨论过他怎么讨好她吗？对。安吉拉打开了一件为猫咪手工编织的Snuggie毯子，镜头切到奥斯卡。他说，我为佩布尔斯做了一件Snuggie。我知道她晚上会冷。背景中，安吉拉对奥斯卡微微点头表示感谢。佩布尔斯。这是一只新猫的登场。这是第一次提到佩布尔斯吗？是的。佩布尔斯。就是这样。这在我们的比莉·艾利什猫咪名单上吗？没有吧，因为它实际上没有在剧集里出现过？我想没有，因为这是在删减片段里。好吧。比莉·艾利什，如果你在听，请注意
there was another cat named Pebbles. Well Toby is still blabbering on and on and Nellie tells him to stop, stop talking. And Toby says, are you going to kiss me? And she says, yes. And then they have a huge passionate makeout. Is this just her truly trying to get him to shut up or is there an attraction here? I don't remember and I don't know. I went to the shooting draft. Okay. It was at first her just trying to get him to shut up.
还有另一只叫佩布尔斯的猫。托比还在喋喋不休地说个不停，内莉让他闭嘴，别再说了。托比说，你要吻我吗？她说，是的。然后他们来了一个极其热烈深情的法式湿吻。这真的是她想让他闭嘴，还是他们之间真有吸引力？我不记得了，我也不知道。我去查了拍摄剧本。好吧。一开始确实只是她想让他闭嘴。
She's like, yeah, sure. Yeah. But then after their smooch, she's like, wow. Like, who, who knew? who knew oh wow uh-huh well everybody that was Dwight's Christmas yes I would like to end with this there were seven Christmas episodes on the office and according to the internet per collider calm if you want to know how the fans ranked them I I can share it with you. All right. Give it to me.
她就觉得，好吧，行吧。但亲完之后，她觉得，哇。就像，谁，谁能想到？谁能想到，哦哇，嗯哼。好吧，以上就是德怀特的圣诞节。是的，我想以这个来结尾：《办公室》里一共有七集圣诞主题剧集，根据互联网上collider.com网站的说法，如果你想知道粉丝们是怎么给它们排名的，我可以跟你分享一下。好啊。快告诉我。
Number one favorite, Classy Christmas. Oh! Second favorite, Christmas Party. Third, Benihana Christmas. Fourth, Secret Santa. Fifth, Dwight's Christmas. Six, Moroccan Christmas. And seventh was Christmas Wishes.
最喜欢的第1名是，优雅的圣诞。哦！第二喜欢的是，圣诞派对。第三，班尼哈娜的圣诞节。第四，秘密圣诞老人。第五，德怀特的圣诞节。第六，摩洛哥的圣诞节。第七是圣诞愿望。
Wow. Seven Christmas episodes, nine seasons. What a ride. I know. Thank you guys so much for listening and rewatching with us, for sending in your questions, your comments. Thank you to Sam for coming and sharing
哇。七集圣诞特辑，九季。真是一段难忘的旅程。我懂。非常感谢大家收听并和我们一起重温，感谢你们发来的问题和评论。感谢萨姆来和我们分享
about his time on Office Ladies. And thank you to Rainn Wilson for your audio clips and Steve Burgess for all your good behind the scenes info and Robert Padnick, our writer. Thank you to Rainn Wilson for your audio clips and Steve Burgess for all your good behind-the-scenes info and Robert Padnick, our writer. Thank you to you as well. Yes, and to my neighbor Creed Bratton for wishing us a happy 200th. And Josh for making the Glufine. Oh my goodness, a lot of people helped us with this episode today. Yes, and to Eduardo for stopping by to get our new full-time engineer Jordan Duffy up
他在《办公室女士》的时光。感谢雷恩·威尔逊提供音频剪辑，感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯提供所有精彩的幕后信息，还有我们的编剧罗伯特·帕德尼克。感谢雷恩·威尔逊提供音频剪辑，感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯提供所有精彩的幕后信息，还有我们的编剧罗伯特·帕德尼克。也谢谢你。是的，还要感谢我的邻居克里德·布拉顿祝贺我们迎来第200期。还有乔治制作的热红酒。哦天哪，今天有好多人帮我们录制这一期节目。是的，还要感谢爱德华多顺道过来帮我们的全职新工程师乔丹·达菲
and running. You guys who listen to the podcast have heard Jordan many times and she also sang a version of Eclipse of the Fart for us. Classic. A classic. And Jordan, what were you just saying to me about the glue wine? I feel like Josh would really want to hear this. I was saying that my sister used to live in Germany and I've been there during times and have had the mulled wine and out of all the wines that I've had in Germany, Josh's is by far one of the best I've had. Well you just made his day, he listens to
上手工作。听播客的朋友们已经听过乔丹很多次了，她还为我们唱了一个版本的《屁之日食》。经典。绝对经典。乔丹，你刚才跟我说什么热红酒来着？我觉得乔治一定很想听听这个。我说我姐姐以前住在德国，我在那儿住过一段时间，喝过热红酒，在我喝过的所有德国热红酒里，乔治做的是我喝过最好喝的之一。好吧，你让他今天心情大好，他每一集
every episode so there you go babe, thanks for making us glue vine. Guys we are gonna take a two-week break for our spring break, and then we will be back with lice. Lice. Oh, it's such a great episode. You're so good in it. And lady, it's either the globe wine and I'm glowing with warmth or I'm having a hot flash. Hmm. OK. Maybe both. Maybe both. See you soon. Bye.
都会收听，所以，宝贝，谢谢你给我们做热红酒。伙计们，我们要为春假休息两周，然后我们会带着《长虱子》回归。《长虱子》。哦，这真是一集太棒的剧了。你在里面表现太棒了。天哪，要么是这热红酒让我浑身发热，要么是我在经历更年期潮热。嗯。好吧。也许两者都有。也许两者都有。回头见。拜拜。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwulf, Jenna Fischer, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Jordan Duffy. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是乔丹·达菲。我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。